pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cher à nice heure et demie bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait avec nous ce soir
dominique loiseau
[Applaudissements]
les gens courent
mariane pearl
jean luc lahaye
hélène grimaud
[Applaudissements]
alain gabriel
mais existe m'atteindre
[Applaudissements]
il sait
millau
la thèse d'un homme team
alors ma fille
on
à
ma vie
bonsoir jean françois collet alors
beaucoup de mails pour demander où tu
étais passé la semaine dernière laurent
je suis allé présenter mon film festival
ouais là et ça s'est bien passé et
chaque mari ou non en outre atlantique
ont été très peur de l'avion s'était pas
c'est un peu une punition enfin le film
a eu un prix dont je suis très content
voilà un prix de quoi prix du public
peut-être la prime aux déplacements
je ne sais pas alors rien du tout ouais
bien une cool don plett je sais que j'ai
oublié mes lunettes nord ont séché pas
dans l'habitude des lunettes un les
presbytes depuis trois semaines et dont
je vais pas pouvoir lire les fiches je
vais pas pouvoir m'intéresser aux
invités donc je ne vais pas pouvoir
venaient ouais donc les gens vont
s'emmerder et les gens vont saper la
casse toi tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
toulouse à la main dans melrose et il
est peut-être qu'elles sont bien quel
est ton prénom petit petit peu ce but
judith rebelles sont très rebelle sont
bien vides on l'a en tout cas j'aime
déjà beaucoup la force fait voir elle se
vend bien laurent fait tout avoir
est ce que tu es ce que tu peux lire il
te faut un chien c'est simple balade sa
wind cannes mais là ça c'est non
bientôt fermer
personne notamment on a des lunettes cet
âge là vraiment si vous avez des
lunettes
moi je suis à 08 ouais pas sur
l'autoroute est ce qu'ils m'ont dit m
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant dominique loiseau
les
[Musique]
et
dominique loiseau bonsoir vous êtes donc
la veuve de bernard loiseau l'un des
plus grands chefs français patron de la
côte d'or à saulieu en bourgogne trois
étoiles au michelin ces fameuses trois
étoiles dont on n'a pas fini d'entendre
parler ce soir et malgré son succès
mondial votre mari bernard loiseau s'est
donné la mort le 24 février dernier en
vous laissant certes trois étoiles mais
aussi trois enfants
ceci étant vous êtes resté stoïque à la
tête de l' affaire digne et courageuse
et aujourd'hui vous lui rendez hommage à
travers un livre qui s'intitule tout
simplement
bernard loiseau mon mari publié aux
éditions michel lafon
alors on va raconter un petit peu sa vie
parce que je crois qu'on va comprendre
toute cette histoire
si on part pas du début à l'école
bernard loiseau n'avais pas de très très
bons résultats il son père l'avait fait
entrer dans un restaurant aussi
extrêmement célèbres qui s'appelle
troisgros à roanne il était apprenti
dans ce restaurant
et puis trois semaines après son arrivée
trois gros obtient sa troisième étoile
au michelin
mais à ce moment là cette troisième
étoile avoir un restaurant 3 étoiles
devient pour votre mari bernard loiseau
une espèce d'obsession de l'obsession
est vrai c'est toute sa vie ça n'a
jamais quitté finalement et
effectivement quand il a eu peur de la
perdre son latin avoir un trois étoiles
c'était son rêve
il mettra 23 ans pour avoir son trois
étoiles il sacrifiera à peu près tout
voilà donc après plein de restaurants
l'oiseau arrive à la côte d'or en 1975
alors un restaurant au glorieux passé
révolu ces restaurants qui a toujours
été à l'époque jean nationale 7
quand les gens nationale 6
vrai qu'entre parier et la côte d'azur à
un moment donné il n'y avait ni avions
ni autorise donc tous les laits les
grands comme charlie chaplin rita
hayworth danny kaye tous ces gens-là
lagat quand ils allaient sur la côte il
allait en deux jours et adressé tech et
du maine à saulieu donc il ya déjà une
histoire très forte dans cette maison là
donc quand ils arrivent là il faut
relever le truc enfin c'est vrai qu'il
ya déjà eu quand même des choses
glorieux oui m'enfin ils sont arrivés
dans cet endroit mais zone n'était pas
très confortables notes réconforte
alors cette époque des temps héroïques 1
on découvre à travers votre livre à ce
moment là un bernard loiseau maniaque
perfectionniste toujours à l'affût de
quelques miettes qui traînent on est
comme ça
ouais non mais dans petites tâches ils
la voyaient une nappe mal repasser ce le
mettait hors de lui les tours de tous et
ils paient tous véritable stakhanoviste
et je raconte ça parce que ça explique
aussi comment il a pu se mettre dans un
état pareil vous vous le rencontrez onze
ans plus tard c'est à dire en 1986
dominique vous travaillez l'époque pour
un journal qui s'appelle l'hôtellerie et
alors il vous ils vous repère un soir
dans une soirée il vous a branché après
oui et puis en plus le drame c'est que
moi j'ai cru que c'était chapelle est-ce
que je ne connaissais pas bien il y
avait quand même une similitude physique
et je me suis dit pourquoi j'appelle mon
regard de toute cette soirée et puis le
lendemain matin j'ai reçu
c'était l'occasion mais s'était envolé
il était déjà parti j'ai pas pu lui dire
tout de suite il était assistant avec
vous donc mais il me regardait tout une
soirée les gens vous fixé pour vous ne
connaissez pas je savais pas ses
lunettes ça peut arriver
et voilà donc au fil des mois vous
devenez dominique sa confidente ils vous
racontent ses gros soucis financiers
parce qu'à l'époque il avait agrandi
l'endroit il vous raconte aussi ses
problèmes puisqu'il est en instance de
divorce et ils trouvent auprès de vous
on peut dire à la fois une oreille et
une épaule et et c'est déjà bien
non c'est vrai mais vous voyez ça oui
absolument
c'est la personne que j'ai connu ce
n'est pas le bernard loiseau tel que
l'aurait fait ces derniers temps et puis
d'ailleurs ne jamais réussi alors quand
même ce qui est assez étonnant c'est dès
ce moment là à l'époque où ils vous
appellent où il vient vous voir à paris
pour vous raconter ses malheurs pour que
vous le soulager un petit peu de ces
problèmes
il pleure beaucoup pas beaucoup mais au
début c'est vrai qu'il pleurait parce
qu'il était dans une phase très
difficile
ouais mais ça vous a pas inquiété cette
fragilité c'est à dire un homme qui
pleure comme ça quand il a des soucis
il avait des soucis grave et ça devrait
pas des heures non plus mais bon quand
quelqu'un vous raconte ses difficultés
et plus leur en même temps ça peut
arriver mais c'est peut-être ce qui m'a
touché aussi oui chez ce personnage
c'est très sensible alors à ce moment là
lui et da et à saulieu évidemment à la
côte d'or vous vous êtes à paris vous
appelle cinq fois par jour à la fois
pour faire le point de la situation sur
ces problèmes financiers ses problèmes
personnels et aussi pour que vous lui
remonter le moral
bien sûr ouais donc c'est quelqu'un
quand même qu'ils avaient besoin de
toujours toujours d'être rassurés et
toujours alors finalement il se sépare
de sa première épouse dont je parle est
un petit peu dans le bouquin oui un
petit peu ça fait parce que ça fait
partie un peu du passé de la maison
les gens de la maison les gens qui
actuellement ont vécu cette période
elle était un peu dépensière quoi oui je
pense
ouais c'est ce lundi pour rencontrer vos
très peu un peu quand même bien alors
vous avez vous installé à saulieu pour
les week-ends
et puis finalement vous marier est imé
questions d'enfants assez rapidement ce
qui est naturel et il lui voue dit à
condition qu'ils dérangent pas le
service ah oui il voulait il était
d'accord pour avoir des enfants mais il
fallait pas que cela ne dérange comme
rien euro ne devaient le déranger ni les
vacances lui ceci c'était le travail et
il fallait que rien ne le dérange
moi j'avais compris cela je me suis dit
les enfants je m'en occuperai est-ce que
vous avez accouché pendant la coupure
non mais nous avons déclenché voilà donc
on a plus attendre pour que sa tombe
ouais pas en plein coup de fusil si je
puis dire mais
c'est vrai que pour la première bon ben
il n'a pas pu assister à ces courageux
et en 1991
arrive enfin ce que notre ami l'oiseau
attendait depuis les cinq ans qui me
disait qu'on allait la voir cette
fameuse étoile donc je me suis dit au
bout de la cinquième région at-on epu et
elle est arrivée la troisième étoile et
vous fêter ça avec vaucluse au son de
cette chanson
[Musique]
c'était le plus beau jour de sa vie non
j'imagine oui c'était c'est l'apogée de
sa vie vous pensé oh je pense oui savez
quand durant des années vous est fixé un
but est que ce but vous l'atteignez bon
il m'était ses chaussettes tous les
jours en disant je dirais qu'à l'e3 est
tout le temps c'était c'était donc après
cette troisième étoile l'impact est
immédiat
il ya des chambres et une boutique une
piscine et un désir après il ya des
niveaux loiseau voilà le groupe loiseau
compte un moment jusqu'à 120 personnes
il lui devient finalement une star
mondiale quoi il a un succès planétaire
il devient sans doute le chef le plus
médiatisé de la profession en france oui
en france étaient plus populaires
populaire et le plus aimé c'était le
cuisinier vraiment des français ouais
alors mitterrand lui remet la légion
d'honneur de niro arrive en jet privé
donc ça c'est vraiment le l'apogée de de
cette histoire bientôt le groupe est
coté en bourse et ce qui est très très
risqué en fait pour un gros risque et
pourquoi est ce que pour lui ça a été
quelque chose de compliqué ce monde des
analystes financiers ont de disons que
cela ce qui l'a déçu c'est que les
analystes ne croient pas en lui comme le
grand public croyait dans le cul mais on
fait pas non plus une action
en trois ans il a bien attendu combien
dadis avoir trois étoiles dont il
fallait être patient
alors on peut penser à un moment en
lisant votre livre que cette apothéose
lui donne un peu le vertige d'une
certaine façon
il se rend compte qu'il est arrivé là au
sommet sa fameuse troisième étoile qu'il
n'a jamais pris le temps de vivre qui
l'a même pas pris de recul sur sa vie
qui est enfermé dans une espèce de
spirale infernale on peut dire voilà
c'est ça tout à fait c'est vrai qu'il a
tout fait pour son travail son il
fallait que rien ne le dérange de son
travail ne fermions jamais non non il
faut pas du tout comparé bernard à
d'autres cuisiniers la plupart ferment
la plupart prennent des vacances la
plupart passe du temps avec leurs
enfants ils ont à auby dernière avait
mis là vraiment c'est un sacerdoce et à
la fin je crois que il n'en pouvait plus
en fait ils découvraient ce moment-là
qu'il ait une troisième étoile mais que
cette troisième étoile c'est pas tout la
vie évidemment il ya d'autres choses
dans la vie il est arrivé un petit peu
au bout de ses rêves
et c'est là où justement nous n'avions
plus de soucis financiers ont commencé à
bien aller on avait trois étoiles on a
maintenant un des plus beaux relais
châteaux d'europe et dans ce coup on
commence à l'égratigner alors que s'est
sacrifié toute sa vie plume bien faire
et à la fin quand il a tout on commença
l'égratigner bon il a toujours su qu'un
jour il y en a qui ne se gênerait pas de
le déboulonner voilà donc à sa hantise à
ce moment là au lieu de passer ce
surplomb disons d'arriver à vraiment
réussir à être heureux à jouir de ce
qu'ils avaient passé autant d'années à à
construire il se renferme un petit peu
dans son univers et se bunkérise comme
on pourrait dire
et effectivement il mélange toujours la
vie privée et la vie professionnelle il
n'y a pas de réunion familiale qu'ils
soient pas perturbés par rapport à un
coup de fil vous raconter ça très bien
y'a pas de vacances n'a pas de loisirs
n'ya pas de cinéma britannique
vous n'allez jamais au resto enfin nous
allons nous avons une très tellement
bonne table chez nous dans l'est pas
c'est pas de pressent pour nous non
sérieusement vous serez le cinéma deux
fois en 15 ans absolument
ouais c'était dur quand même oui mais
après je me suis habitué
faut pas se tromper la fusée habitués et
vous restez soit vous ne restez pas
avoir une merde
intérêt à voir un bon film justement le
dise alors c'est vrai qu'il est quand
même s'il est très touchant dans votre
bouquin c'est que c'est vrai il a
conscience de ça il vous dit je
t'achèterai une maison sur la côte
d'azur
soit il sait très bien qu'il faut en
profiter à un moment mais il arrive pas
il
oui disons qu'il avait toujours reporter
ça plus tard ils savaient qu'ils
devaient trim et rim et trimer pour
réussir pour obtenir une belle maison et
là on n'arrivait presque au bout il
disait après je ferai ceci toujours un
prêt depuis 50 ans depuis qu'il a eu 50
ans il commençait à vouloir se préserver
à dire maintenant il va falloir faire
attention et et puis malheureusement on
n'a pas réussi alors un jour finalement
vous partez quatre jours en
thalassothérapie
là c'est un évènement imprévu dans tous
les cas c'est bien repasse historicité
et aux revenants
il vous dit faut que je reparte touche
fasse un break faut qu'on prenne des
vacances et il dit je vais partir en
vacances est là c'est assez inquiétant
il vous dit même si tu viens pas j'irai
mais oui parce qu'on n'a pas trouvé là
de date quant lui avait une semaine moi
j'aurais rendez-vous des engagements et
il faudra que je partirai a même tout
seul je dis pas de souci si tu lui as
besoin dans mon art il faut par ailleurs
bon j'étais quand même d'accès au fond
de moi bien sûr il a il commence à faire
des remarques de plus en plus des foetus
quoi ils visent à vis de moi il en a
parlé au personnel à tout le monde bien
soin mais ça a duré quelques mois se
remarque un petit peu extravagante
parfois voilà exagéré tellement exagéré
qu'on ne pouvait pas le croire donc
bernard était quelqu'un qui exagéraient
bien des choses donc c'est pour ça qu'on
n'a pas bu bien pu mesurer le la
profondeur de la pathologie un soir il
vous dit je vais me suicider oui ou non
utilisées et puis je crois que je vais
me suicider dominique alors je lui dis
je lui ai dit je les disputer ouais tu
dis qu'on ne dit pas des choses
pareilles
mais là j'aime pas de raison la cantine
enfants à ce moment là vous vous doutez
pas une seconde que ça puisse être
envisageable pour lui assure que non
mais là sera toujours été du genre à
exagérer les choses chaque fois qu'ils
me donnaient un chiffre jeudi bernard et
moi le vrai chiffre divisé division par
2 c'était son c'était son style voilà il
24 février sur une balle dans la tête
personne n'aurait pu n'aurait pu
soupçonner qu un être qui est à
surmonter les pires difficultés
vraiment les pires qu'une difficulté
s'installer dans un endroit pas facile
une maison qui lui appartenait pas à
devoir l'a racheté héberger des
milliards à écrire il se met sur le dos
aux le meilleur de crédit non vous savez
les banques ne nous prêtent pas plus que
vous ne pouvez en pensez mais quand même
il sait que tout cet égard de sentir oui
mais des milliards de centimes mais tout
était bien il n'y a pas de souci de ce
côté là sauf que à cette agression oui
et puis il sacrifier lui-même je veux
dire sa propre cuisine dans sa maison on
l'a fait en 98 voyez sa propre cuisine
avant on avait une petite cuisine avec
un micro ondes et bien qu'en donnant les
plus mal chaussés la voilà non mais lui
c'était tout à fait cela mais il savait
qu'un jour ils auraient ça et c'est pour
ça qu'il visait toujours un jour un jour
mais il avait mis peut-être il s'était
peut-être trop privé il serait trop dur
et on peut peut-être pas dû parce que
c'est ce qu'il avait cassé son ressorts
intérieurs peut-être là c'est parce que
vous avez beaucoup rire ça ne
vous arrêtez pas de temps en temps pour
souffler vous n'aurez pas longtemps
est-ce qu'il n'a pas tellement dépenser
de l'énergie pour les autres qui n'en
avait plus pour lui il était bien
beaucoup de gens ont dit qu'il est mort
de générosité exactement il donné de sa
personne il voyait tous les clients est
passé beaucoup de temps avec eux y
passer du temps avec son personnel
il était très généreux alors le mini
qu'on va pas donner de détails macabres
sur cette journée vous raconter ça dans
votre bouquin c'est assez c'est assez
touchant ce que je retiens c'est que le
soir même le 24 février le service est
assuré comme à l'accoutumée oui ça moi
je n'y suis pour rien puisque j'étais à
la maison en train de prévenir la
famille gendarmes arriver donc et en
fait c'est le directeur de la salle très
décidé de terminer le service les
clients étaient venus de loin ils
avaient des chambres le score on
n'allait pas leur dire écoutez aller
manger à côté show must go on n'allait
pas je n'allais pas gâcher leur soirée
c'est ça ensuite vous vous reprenez les
rênes du groupe
rien ne s'arrête un tout et toujours
comme avant il ya des nouveaux plats ça
marche toujours aussi bien la clientèle
est toujours là vous avez fait froncer
bien évidemment maintenant la question
qui se pose c'est pourquoi alors la
troisième étoile justement vous dit
qu'il savait qu'il a conservée en fait
cette troisième étoile donc à paris
vient pas eu d'inquiétude puisque avant
même la publication du guide michelin il
savait qu'il gardait cette troisième
étoile
bien sûr qui a dit légitimement il
aurait dû la perdre
c'est un journal un journal qui a dit ça
un journaliste bon quand on dit
légitimement ce qu'il parle au nom du
michelin
il faudrait qu'ils se renseignent ou
alors il ne l'espère qu'il est venu chez
nous récemment aussi pour pouvoir dire
cela mais ça j'en suis même pas sûr lors
sa selle a beaucoup violent il avait
gardé
son étoile mais ça il vous a dit de
chercher dictionnaire on va regarder des
équipements ce que ça veut dire quoi
exactement
et là il s'est dit il ya un complot ils
commencent à se mettre tous contre moi
parce qu'ils attendent et ils savaient
que comme il était connu comme il est en
train de réussir qui annexe attendait
cela le sens de l'honneur d'un autre
siècle
oui également également absolument alors
il ya pas mal d'articles de presse à ce
moment là effectivement qui sont
négatifs sur lui notamment le figaro a
pas mal et ghana il ya deux fois le
figaro points
il n'a pas d'autre et la chambre
syndicale publié un communiqué en disant
ce sens les journalistes quand tu es
maintenant il est n a pas été publié
c'est une note interne qui
malheureusement a été diffusé allez
c'est une note interne qui de faire une
réunion pour un peu voir ce que vaut ce
que ce qu'ils pouvaient faire
et moi je n'ai jamais dit que c'était
les critiques qui n'ont tu as un c'est
un ensemble de choses
et excusez moi de vous dire ça dominique
va vous mettre les critiques à dos de
toute façon déjà mais en plus si messi
mais honnêtement si j'avais senti qu'il
y avait des gens vraiment responsable je
crois que je n'aurais pas pu m'empêcher
de suite de de réagir non mais je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui avait
perturbé bernard ces derniers temps là
l'avenir la cuisine française enfin
mais surtout il avait pris il sentait
qu'on allait la tuer voyez ouais alors
la troisième étoile on a vu laver la
presse effectivement il a eu quelques
articles dans le figaro dites-vous de
négatif
alors il ya la note du gault millau qui
est passée de 19 sur 20 à 17 sur 20 on
n'était pas les seuls d'ailleurs
beaucoup de grands chefs qui sont passés
à cette note là ouais c'était pas outre
mesure quelque chose alors il a dit il à
dire accuse il a dit à bocuse tu te
rends compte je suis des classes et donc
ça c'était peut-être une raison à ça
mais j'avais beaucoup de téléphone tous
les jours non normal qu'ils lui disent
cela vous en parlez pas dans votre
bouquin de cette note
parce que je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'accessoires vous pouvez aussi me
dire parce que j'ai passé avec ne
voulait pas du tout mais pas du tout
mais je veux dire gobillot sont des
découvreurs bon nous on a une cuisine un
peu plus classique maintenant qui est
une cuisine de goût
ou comprendre notre cuisine on n'a pas
une cuisine d'effets spéciaux on n'a pas
une cuisine de laboratoire expérimental
donc c'est normal que privilégie
peut-être un peu les cuisines plus
exubérante voie la plus innovante
donc quelle raison la troisième étoile
le gaultmillau les emprunts c'est un
ensemble de choses c'est quelqu'un qui
était hyper fatigué sous cette fatigue
s'est installée une dépression nous on a
cru que c'était de la fatigue d'une
grave dépression
c'était quelqu'un de bipolaire c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait soit il était tout
feu tout flamme soit il était très
tendue mais de quoi voilà cyclothymique
et là à ce moment là sont tombés des
petites attaques qu'on ne peut pas
condamner parce que c'est de bonne
guerre
il y en a eu
déjà eu gier mais généralement il
balayait ça d'un revers de main hélas il
y a beaucoup de choses qui ont dû
s'accumuler sur lui et puis ces cas de
déprime grave quand on discute avec des
spécialistes les personnes sont
déconnectés prononce at il dit dans son
dernier bouquin tout ce que les gens
disent tout autour de lui il dit causses
toujours
c'est un peu site de raisonner quelqu'un
impose dans une dépression nerveuse pour
lui raconter qui va très bien et vous
dis non je vais mal nous avons tous
discuter discuter des heures avec son
directeur de restauration avec son avec
son chef avec moi on a tous essayé de
lui dire qu'il y avait aucun souci et
une apparemment ils nous écoutent et
déjà plus la bipolarité c'est encore
plus pernicieux parce que tu as le
terrain des moments de dépression
profonde avec des moments d'euphorie
d'enseignement de fourmis peuvent
rassurer les proches examen hier mais
avec les clients bernard était il
fallait le voir et discuter avec ses
clients et c'est quelqu'un qui se peser
tous les matins qui ne se laissait pas
du tout il n'y avait pas de signe qui
puisse me dire attention il se laisse
aller dans tous les cas il vous a pas
laissé de petits mots de message pour
vous dire pourquoi c'est bizarre ça non
il ne m'est pas écrire de tout ça ne
m'étonne pas là puis vous dire un truc
si le même fruit mais j'ai passé
d'autant plus symbolique voulu on
voulait non parce que je sais qu'il a
fait de façon inconsciente je ne peux
pas leur en vouloir
parfois je râle oui parce que j'ai
beaucoup de travail parce que je m'en
sors pas parce que c'est pas facile à
gérer mais
je ne lui en veux pas parce que je sais
que c'était une fragilité c'était
quelque chose d'inconscient pour ce
qu'il a fait ça dans un état second et
que c'est pas lui qui a fait sa une ce
tam séisme qu'est ce qui vous manque le
plus aujourd'hui sa présence
monsieur sa présence vous appeler
beaucoup vous étiez très portable et
tout le temps il m'appelait tout le
temps au téléphone même quand j'étais
dans le bureau au dessus il m'appelait
tout le temps il me disait de raconter
tout ce qui se passait et et puis bon
ben c'est c'est bernard c'est un chef
d'entreprise qui a disparu c'est
quelqu'un à meneur d'hommes
c'est pas facile quand on leur donne
disparaît sans parler de l'aspect
personnel de mon mari qui a disparu mais
déjà l'histoire de deux titres vous le
verrez et il est seulement
surtout au moment où il pouvait enfin il
aurait pu profiter de ses 27 ans
sacrifices
maintenant il était et il arrivait au
bout de tout cela vous avez au cimetière
attendant bien sûr bien sûr et c'est là
où j'ai sous la main non moins bien
booster voulue par l'état mois nous dit
des trucs pas vous sentez des choses
sont quand même mais nous agissons tous
dans cette maison comme s'il était là
que vous l'entendez gueuler encore
parfois dans la maison sa voix est très
présente il est très présent même les
clients le dise
c'est un bon metteur en scène alors
quand c'est arrivé je suis pas qu'on
vous l'a reproché mais beaucoup ont été
surpris de ne pas vous voir pleurer je
dirais et vous dites pleurer devant les
caméras ne l'aurais pas fait revenir
mais ça vous a quand même collé une
étiquette de femme froide
oui je sais je sais mais bon il faut
parfois on peut voir comment tout ça
s'est passé
le lendemain matin tous les médias et
c'est dans ce lieu et nous avons fait
une réunion avec
la direction avec un lait
les gens tous les chefs de service et un
nazi qu'est ce qu'on fait et on a dit la
côte d'or va continuer l'établissement
on continue en continu pour bernard et à
partir de cela il fallait que quelqu'un
le dise bon quand on veut faire passer
un message c'est pas en pleurant qu'on
fait passer un message
bon d'une part nous avions décidé de
continuer deuxièmement je savais que
bernard était décédé dans des conditions
d'inconscience donc il fallait quand
même il ya un minimum d'honneur et de
dignité je veux dire il fallait pas
montrer que tout s'écroule il fallait
justement essayer de difficile à
expliquer et en même temps si vous
décidez de continuer si vous pleuré
devant les médias pearson va venir
durant de trois mois déjà et puis en
plus on ne sait jamais comment les
images sont utilisés on ne sait jamais
nous nous c'est une pièce de théâtre
quand on vient chez nous n'importe
quelle personne n'a encore maintenant à
perdre et les membres de l'équipe
même s'ils ont des problèmes chez eux
ils sont pas sensés et montrer à leurs
clients on est souriant devant nos
clients on vend du bonheur donc si on
vend du bonheur on ne peut pas donner
ces images-là ces images là on les garde
pour nous et il ya une image que l'on
donne aux clients et aux autres et on a
notre image nous on est en choisissant
d'une certaine façon j'ai eu la chance
de tomber sur une femme comme vous parce
que vous continuez vous appliquez des
mômes et de le faire oui tout seul mais
parce que mange tout seul oui bien sûr
mais bon il ya plus de travail à faire
on a des chefs d'equipe qui ont toujours
eu l'habitude d'être d'avoir beaucoup de
responsabilités donc cela continue et
puis ça nous a soudés et puis c'est une
volonté c'est un chef qui fédère vous
savez c'est un créateur qui a su
transmettre son savoir il n'y en a pas
beaucoup et lui a su le faire
vous dites je continue pour pas qu'ils
meurent deux fois bien sûr parce que sa
bille c'était cette maison ouais je sais
puisque j'en ai assez souffert de cela
on a tout sacrifié pour cela donc je
veux quand même pas qu'ils se soient
faits pour rien tout ça même si lui a
malheureusement disparu
il faut pas que son oeuvre disparaissent
si c'était à refaire vous feriez quoi
pas pareil bah on essaierait peut-être
de lui faire comprendre qu'il faut
fermer deux jours par semaine
ouais ça peut être une question de vie
et de mort parfois et qu' il faut avoir
des hobbies et qui ce que j'ai toujours
essayé de lui faire comprendre mais sa
vie bernard était quelqu'un quand même
d' autoritaire et quand il avait décidé
quelque chose c'était pas facile de
faire changer
et puis en fait quand même deux fois par
an ah ouais ça fait pas beaucoup c'est
aussi un peu des chasses relationnel
pour voir vous avez aujourd'hui pas
avoir tapé du poing sur la table en
disant moi je me barre en vacances tu te
barres pas avec moi tant pis je pars
plus de sel ou lui mettre la pression
comme ça savez quand on épouse quelqu'un
on épouse jamais la personne idéale
quand on a imaginé donc il faut soit on
accepte la personne et puis il ya des
choses vous voyez bien ce que la
personne va changer et puis à des choses
qu'on ne peut pas changer chez les gens
et bernard c'est un gagneur c'était son
c'est un projet de vie donc on accepter
tous vous pouvez voir tout son personnel
on était tous discret à côté de lui on
s'est toujours battu à ses côtés et on
continue de se battre pour lui merci
dominique
on n'arrive pas revenue
vous permet de voir la personnalité de
non
et aussi le milieu de la restauration à
puce a servi très intéressant merci
beaucoup merci damas
[Musique]
m
voilà bernard loiseau mon mari par
dominique loiseau c'est que éditions
michel lafon est maintenant chez au tour
meeting géant
du dynamo
je les trouve par hasard ouais c'est
christine deviers joncour
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si les gens courant bonsoir manificat
revient toujours très très élégante et
sexy bah oui moi aussi moi aussi surtout
qu'on me reproche souvent on me dit
thierry la pâte on fait la liste des
choses qu'on peut me reprocher il ya
toujours elle tend à ensorceler dans
tout le monde en parle et on me dit ça à
chaque fois qu'on me parle de mes fautes
supposées peut-être en tous les cas très
lassant tout est toujours de ma faute
voilà ça fait sept ans que ça dure et
c'est vrai qu'elle est bonne
serena c'est vrai mais c'est vrai que
des compliments
tu répudier encore bonne soirée et est
désobligeant dans la première fois que
vous êtes venu christine dans tout le
monde en parle
ma vie' raconter des mensonges vous avez
cru voilà j'avais raconté à tout le
monde c'est pâques à vous raconter aux
juges pendant des années voilà c'est ça
des mois afp potes c'est pas d'oubli
vous êtes un petit peu plus sincère est
aujourd'hui non pas quand nora monae
nous causent moi qui parle ce sont les
autres je parle d'autre chose voilà
alors c'est eu laurent que christine
deviers-joncour est devenu christine
tuffin dj deviers joncour justin dj
incroyable j -cd jdj voilà pourquoi dj
je suis pas un disque je khaimah ou
pourriez un mondial coté jockey en tout
cas voilà
alors vous écrivez vous écrivez bon plus
trouble sur les affaires maintenant vous
écrivez des nos paroles de chansons vous
composez vous chantez et voilà le
résultat
ma
c'est mieux
my
ce qu'on peut mettre le disque à la
vitesse normale par correction pour
l'artiste bien minimum quand on reçoit
les gens soient masculins mon féminin
christine dg dont les deux titres
1 voilà très très jolie titouan la
parole et musique de christine deviers
joncour je veux dire l'avouer tout fait
ce pas le cas de tous les morceaux
j'écris j'écris dans les cinq titres et
à trois textes qui sont deux mois voilà
ce qui n'est pas de moi ayant un remix
il promet alors christine c'est une
passion la chanson qui vous est venu sur
le tard ou c'est parce que vous étiez
tricarde de partout vous avez fait la
chanson c'est cardozo mais la musique
non la musique j'ai j'ai appris la
musique quand j'avais 9 ans d'ailleurs
vous allez voir comme le destin est
quand même très étrange
à 9 ans mes parents voulu que j'apprenne
la musique qui voulait que j'apprenne
accordéon piano doit donner les noms du
piano
le piano pas le viol violences havas
media après vous je voulais a fallu
quand même épreuve avait pas beaucoup de
6 ces instits il m'a dit le pire ne
pourra jamais lui offrir ce sera
l'accordéon piano et figurez vous qu à
sarlat ouais china daily
non c'est vrai mais au festival du film
de sarlat redescend sont bas mais quel
festival du film mais j'ai des bons
d'essence ont fait la fête à sarlat oui
je connais une boutique de chaussures
comme ça dans le sang mais juste
nantes est à sarlat
il ya très longtemps un espagnol qui
avait fui le franquisme et qui s'étaient
réfugiés dans le périgord noir et qui a
rencontré une femme il a fait deux
petites filles et s'est trouvé coincé là
prix les plus grands partis est cet
homme était appelé un grand avenir là
bas dans son pays en espagne
il devait être compositeur et chef
d'orchestre et sa carrière pour lui
s'est brisé à sarlat et il a vu arriver
la petite christine schraner gens des
gens et chiens l'instant besoins en
béton ferment parce qu'on est ce parce
qu'on a l'impression des cartes de bons
qui a tout de suite vous revenez quand
vous voulez cost espagnole de saint
théophile christina 9 ans qui en plus
l'accordéon est lourd je suis pas très
épaisse et moi j'ai un rêve c'est
entendre le piano allons commencer
dictée musicale et peu à peu
j'étais tellement heureuse entendu piano
qui m'a fait faire de l'harmonie ce qui
fait qu pendant douze ans j'ai travaillé
l'harmonie en trichant me disais pas mes
parents en méprisant l'instrument donc
j'aurais dû normalement être chef
d'orchestre et compositeur
voilà comment j'ai fini chez elf
et
j'étais ici
my
ça dessert le disque je vous le dis mais
par rapport à votre passé effectivement
soir et étaient tenus de lancer une
ligne de chaussures non c'est non mais
j'aurais dû ouais ouais ouais c'est pas
trop tard tu savais christine quand même
que dans la chanson faut parfois coucher
pour réussir on est au courant quand
même dans la chanson est important pour
elle il faut coucher c'est le cas il ya
un truc est certain c'est pas encore
touché peut-être ça viendra mais là je
serai là je ferais bien attention je
couche a encore pas bien quel cinéaste
américain
alors le fait que vous ayez fait de la
prison est très bon pour votre image
vas-y un côté gangsta rap comme ça ça
donne un côté il ya un côté roots comme
ça je trouve maintenant vraiment mais
vous savez que passait par là s'est pas
complètement négatif non plus mais bon
on au poly des fois on peut passer par
les gagner la partie
non non j'ai pas touché 200 francs un
membre les a pris vous savez quand même
que la chanson ça rapporte moins que la
vente de frégates à taïwan quand même
attention ces dépenses qu'on vend et la
loi que je fais ça pour marcher alors je
fais ça d'abord pourquoi courir je fais
ça parce que j'aime je fais ça parce que
derrière moi j'ai des musiciens
formidables
on y reviendra que dessine alors on
parlait des frégates de taïwan juste un
titre de chanson qui n'est pas sur
l'album régal de taiwan à venir les
statuettes demi album qui sort en
janvier y aura peut-être le titre tu
choisis combien mon humble avis des
chansons
blatter
justement un mandat avant de revenir
avant de revenir aux discussions et
qu'on dise quelques mots de cette
affaire de frégate parce que vous savez
que thierry jean-pierre ex juge jean
pierre était assis à votre place il ya
quelques semaines pour parler de son
bouquin taiwan connection alors c'est
incroyable parce que je comprend un
petit peu au coeur de quoi vous étiez à
l'époque je me rendais pas compte huit
morts huit morts inexpliquées 5
milliards de francs disparu par pour
tout le monde vous me direz et puis pas
pour ceux dont les noms dorment dans un
coffre c'est à dire le juge jean pierre
nous a expliqué qu'il y avait dix neuf
personnes dont les noms ont été reportés
sur une feuille de papier dans un coffre
et que monsieur fabius et monsieur maire
avait interdit la publication de ces
noms au nom du secret défense qui
d'habitude doit s'appliquer plus tôt
pour la défense que pour le pognon enfin
- ouais vous vous souvenez quand je suis
venu vous voir avec mon livre opération
branchement secteurs de l'île
ouais d'accord en 2000 j'étais la seule
moi me battre sur cette affaire avec des
gilets pare-balles et vous rappeler je
vous disais que j'avais des contrats
sûrement tout le monde rigolait appel je
faisais que j'avais je vais j'avais mon
gilet pare-balles en votre vestiaire
tout le monde rigolait c'est comme
turenne aujourd'hui c'est même pas dix
morts on parle de presse bon dirigeant
pierre didi autour de dimanche on parle
de 18 morts ça veut dire que moi quand
je suis venu vous voir et coopération
bravo j'avais un mort celui de taïwan
le capitaine in depuis l'année dernière
en juin il y en avait sept j'avais déjà
froid dans le dos et là aujourd'hui
j'apprends qu'elle n'a peut-être 18 en
tout cas disent bien sonnés et je me
demande comment je suis encore en vie et
que j'étais moi la première à dénoncer
ce scandale est que je suis allé à
taiwan et que j'ai pris tous les risques
pour que ça sort que c'est une horreur
cela m'a dit qu'est ce qu'il faut savoir
aujourd'hui est que les français doivent
savoir c'est que le secret défense ou
jeu normalement est là pour servir tout
ce qui est secret technologique mais
c'est très décente
on ne le lève pas pourquoi parce que on
protège tout ce qui est financier
ça veut dire que si on lève le secret
défense aujourd'hui on va savoir le nom
des gens qui ont touché en france 5
milliards de francs de rétrocommissions
- d'accord ça veut dire quoi
vous les connaissez vous les dix des
dix-neuf non vous les connaissez je les
connais des bruits circulent moi ça fait
six ans et en disant que j'entends
circuler les bruits mais on n'a pas les
preuves pour que l'épreuve ont tous
qu'on est les preuves que le jugement
une béquille à tous les courages et
l'épreuve
il faut qu'on lève le secret défense ils
ne veulent pas que ce soit les ministres
de droite qui est minime c'est bien
parce que mr attendre en panne et bien
sûr pas que des petits lumineux de
points rouges les mineures je crois que
le pire cette histoire c'est que vous
savez que taiwan se porte partie civile
oui oui j'ai vu alors attendez oui c'est
que taiwan se porte partie civile la
france d'être obligé de de perrault moss
avec les intérêts 70 me ce faisceau
millions euros pour les contrôles y
entre on se bat là et dans le même temps
l'argent sera débloqué parce qu'il est
bloqué en suisse et comme on peut pas
continuer la procédure
l'argent sera débloqué et sera là bien
donner aux gens qui ont quand même pu
avancer les contribuables vont encore
payer le fait de dénoncer tout ça ça te
mets pas ça ne protège pas un petit peu
de liens tu veux que je te dise je les
ai pris les risques
je suis pas morte inch'allah je suis là
il paraît que c'est grâce à 80% des
français 81% des français aurait soit
disant c'est que ''c'était pont qui
m'aimait bien qui fait qu' on ne
manquait pas tuer pour pas créer un
syndrome de martyrs voilà moi c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit
je pense
quand je pense que tout le monde est un
fléau majeur la [__] de la retenue
dans les pas vous êtes vous êtes jeanne
d'arc à l'hébreu sainte une seule
essence or vous savez les hymnes sont
comme chez vous quand j'écris ce premier
livre
ils sont par esi mais banon mais sans
trouver c'est pas mieux
son patron jean république vous savez le
titre que je voulais vadam ans eva joly
qui m'avait appelé comme ça
de fait les juges je voulais mettre les
[__] de la république et à l'époque
tous mes avocats de l'époque me disais
oh la la il faut pas faire ça les juges
vont tomber dessus tout le monde va vous
tomber dessus vous en avez assez sur le
dos effectivement le fusible est déjà
bien chargé
donc j'ai pas osé mais aujourd'hui je
lui crie haut et fort c'est pas la
[__] à glisser les [__] de la
république c'est clair
permettez moi quand même de trouver
extraordinaire le fait que tout le monde
sic il ya 19 noms dans un coffre que
c'est les gens qui ont touché des
rétrocommissions et que en fait il reste
dans le coffre et quoi qu'on dise la la
télévision sur france 2 le samedi soir
ça changera rien à la veille à une
émission sur france 3 qui est passée
pièces à conviction 90 minutes où ils
vous disent tout et où ils lisent lui
c'est même à la fin on dit les gens pas
venu lui parler on a eu des menaces à
temps mais si c'est qu'est ce que c'est
ce pays vous donner un exemple de noms
qui est dans le coffre
juste les émissions riches en un
je peux prendre un coup de fusil sa
femme c'est ça ouais je suis content
permettez-moi de noter quand même que si
à 19,9 enfermé dans un coffre et qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'y accéder c'est pas
la démocratie je veux dire c'est clair
donc quand vous en doutiez bien alors
moi j'ai une question est ce que ces
commissions et ces rétro commissions
sont prises par des partis politiques
des hommes politiques des militaires des
dirigeants d'entreprises sur la vente
des frégates ou est-ce qu'au contraire
ils ont organisé la vente des frégates
pour prendre des rétrocommissions super
bonne question
bonne question mais aussi aux phoques
quand je travaillais pour faire sortir
ce ce dossier des frégates signé ce
contrat
on parlait de créer de l'emploi ont
parlé des chantiers navals très fermé en
parler en parler ça et moi j'avais
l'impression de faire quelque chose qui
était bon pour la france et ça
m'encourage et c'était aussi ma façon de
pousser d'humains à trouver une solution
diplomatique avec la chine de pékin
bon c'est vrai que moi j'y ai cru et
puis au fur et à mesure des années qui
s'écroule et de ce qu'on est en train de
vivre là je me dis m'attend mais moi
aussi j'ai été manipulé mais j'étais
gravement manipuler en fait je en train
d'apprendre aujourd'hui que toute cette
affaire a été montée pour s'en foutent
plein les poches tous donc les ventes
ont été orientés fait ce boulot monsieur
en prison - gérante du 60 millions de
francs surtout donné le fils comment
demande aujourd'hui 70 et c'est eux ils
sont en train de toucher itunes non mais
attends mais on est où là
christine sérieusement non je suis dit
non mais soit faire parler musique
lauren intensité et c'est ça qui est
terrible et c'est ça qui est terrible
c'est que vous tous que ce soit la télé
la presse la presse écrite la radio
pendant six ans vous avez été tous
manipulés parce que à part les 116 de
christine et de roland delattre
sémantique a chuté de manipuler la
raison la raison tant il n'y a rien à
cacher tout à fait et on est con comme
des bits ou quoi et oui à racheter les
fêtes on sait manipuler tirer oui bien
sûr non ceci étant fait des goûters nosy
bé c'est désormais à nous de votre
question c'est vrai nom c'est vrai je
reconnais moi thierry ardisson en tous
les cas que des gens courent dumas ça
nous a caché la sphère des frégates qui
était en fait la grosse affaire alors
c'est vrai qu'on découvre en lisant le
livre de thierry jean-pierre en relisant
opération bravo on découvre qu'on fait
si thomson avait accepté de payer sirven
pour les services rendus auprès de
roland dumas par votre intermédiaire il
y aurait non seulement jamais eu dhafer
el djamil affaires médicales méconnu la
ferté les contribuables français
n'aurait jamais su qu'elle 5 milliards
de francs qui ont été parfaitement
étouffé
non alors du mahdi thierry jean-pierre a
changé d'avis après un week-end avec
vous à pékin alors pouvez pas dire qu'il
dit n'importe quoi là alors que tout à
leurs visées qui disait la vérité et non
le voile non pas pour ça c'est pas il le
dit pas comme ça c'est vous qui faites
encore d'un car non pas des fous j'ai
des raisons non qu'est ce qui s'est
passé pour arriver à faire changer
roland dumas d'avis sur les frégates
durant un week-end à pékin il a fallu
nettoyer qu'elle n'a fait qu'un tour
vossen et négocier déjà quelques
quelques semaines avant le voyage à
pékin le voyage à pékin n'a été que la
finale à c'était c'était en finale
c'était la récompense
la cerise sur le gâteau
la chinoiserie ça se négocie là bas
aussi passé négocier pourquoi qui va
marcher à taïwan le disque non oui vous
êtes une star
oui ils m'adorent à taïwan ils
m'attendent
ils veulent que j'aille elle donnait des
cancers là bas mais je vais y aller sur
une frégate ça serait bien
toi masculin mon féminin d'encre et
steve dg extrait donc du cd 5 titres
l'album c'est l'an prochain alors dont
vous allez faire des petits concerts
comme savignon à toulouse à brive la
gaillarde commence oui mais c'est bien
dans des marins sont des petits showcase
à 18h le soir gratuits donc très bien je
vais je vais déjà me frotter un peu la
scène c'était dans live c'est le premier
rang dans un premier temps et après et à
l'album qui arrive en jouant avec le
livre de particulier c'est quoi c'est un
livre érotique
oui 2 comment vous savez je vous vois
bien puisqu'un petit graphique à la
terre elle s'est pas totalement oublié
un moment j'ai une chanson mais si dans
une chanson qui s'appelle dernier
message vous avez une phrase assez jolie
d'ailleurs vous dites il m'a lâché un
soir d'hiver tu m'as laissé les faits
divers thiam dont c'est bien on peut
rien vous cacher ouais vous lisez entre
les lignes
battez-vous des paroles fumée
je veux lancer un soir d'hiver tu vas
laisser c'est facile quand on a la bonne
vitesse alors je vois très bien à qui
s'adresse à g le village est de la vente
de votre disque cette chanson à mon avis
est consacrée à roland qui était assis
là ya pas longtemps qu un type charmant
que j'aime beaucoup
ah bon ah oui pirola émission il
regrette depuis vos joueurs bien alors
il ya aussi une chanson qui s'appelle
sans domicile fixe est-ce que c'est
autobiographique
à part ça vous avez une maison à sarlat
j'espère ici pas de liste et vous avez
dormi avec le lot j'ai une adresse chez
mon avocate à marseille a ajouté patrick
à nador et elle a reçu une saisie
conservatoire sur les meubles cabinet
avocat parce que nul berlin
je n'ai plus d'après ce jeu les erreurs
mais moi je te berges
je suis ruiné ma vie mais non je
présente ma voix je vois je ne deviez
pas s'il faut dire que même si je ne
pose chez quelqu'un peut pas me donner
son adresse il peut être saisi dans les
camps dit car je n'ai plus la presse
j'ai plus compte en banque
je n'ai plus rien et sur le plan
judiciaire vous avez tous si pour
sectionner j'attends la cassation
oui mais j'ai encore normalement de la
prison oui vous avez été condamné en
janvier 2003 en appel à 18 mois de
prison ferme et douze mois avec sursis
et commence à la grèce
effectivement franchement quand je fais
les comptes 18 mois ferme 12 mois avec
sursis vous avez fait six mois il vous
reste 12 à faire quoi
il reste trois mois et demi à trois mois
lors des remises de peine à l'oral qu'à
des remises de peine sur chaque année il
ya des revenus ses peines
donc il se fait à trois ans ferme ses
trois mois et demi oui pénitencier
bientôt
vance
le fermer
[Musique]
on ira vous on ira vous voir mais c'est
quoi trois mois et demi c'est beaucoup
quand on est enfermé sur 3 mètres sur
deux un bon principe at t tu adores la
scène des mineurs
justement qui signe ce procès en appel
était a été très dur pour vous et
ensuite vous êtes un petit peu repliés
sur vous même pourquoi il était si dur
ce procès en appel il était dur parce
que parce que parce que je reprends
encore de la prison parce qu'on n'a pas
ouvert le dossier des frégates
c'est forcément qu'il faut comme le
condamne puisque l'on sait pas pourquoi
on vous accuse d'avoir pris d'argent va
ouvrir le dossier où vous êtes vous
expliquer pourquoi faisait gagner star
jeu et on peut pas ouvrir ce dossier des
frégates parce que vous avez vu pourquoi
maintenant c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est justement pierre voilà donc c'est
ce que je dis depuis toujours je ne
saurai jamais juger équitablement si on
n'ouvre pas le dossier frigga l'argent
que vous me reprochez il est gagné sur
la non jamais voulu non c'est normal je
retourne en prison ça tue sérieusement
vous êtes une espèce d'erreur judiciaire
art vivant de quoi non c'est pas une
erreur dit yacine affaire d'état et
quand on temple là dedans mais il ya des
fusibles
ils sont là pour ça pour laver l'honneur
de la république française voilà vous
êtes pas le la [__] de la république
en fait vous êtes le cache misère
ouais ouais alors vous êtes replier sur
vous même durant ce procès en appel et
ensuite vous êtes parti en province vous
êtes le parti vous réfugier chez vous et
là c'est le retour vous dit
l'écriture de chansons c'est le seul
moment où j'arrive un peu oublié le
reste et être heureuse
oui l'écriture de toute façon l'écriture
j'ai écrit quand même quatre livres j'en
ai écrit trois pour me défendre
ouais ça une bonne raison ça ça me
permettait de tenir et de me battre
et puis et puis j'ai pris l'habitude
d'écrire et puis là on sort là c'est
vrai que ça ne soit remise à écrire tout
de suite mais là d'autres choses là
maintenant l'amour c'est chaud un peu
ses shows de boucane
mais si jamais eu de guerre jamais comme
le passage sur le prépuce qui fait 82 ça
passe comme une lettre à la poste
il est décédé quand il y avait des
désaccords garde bien ri c'est que non
seulement j'écris le bonheur de
l'écriture on oublie tout quand on écrit
tous ses soucis tous ces problèmes mais
en même temps je chante donc j'ai à la
fois la musique les paroles et la
musique est autre chose quand on écrit
on est seul et là je suis pas seul parce
qu'il ya toute une équipe derrière moi
quand tu vas chanter tu vas pas
énormément de monde le sait déjà
attention et péter le week-end dernier
je t'ai pas ça sérieusement et l'amour
dans tout ça et oui sérieux christine
vous en êtes où vous avez quelqu'un dans
votre vie ah ouais pas ça vous intéresse
je vais leur en parler avec vous il veut
savoir on avoue au passage il n'y a pas
que moi je disais
jean veil sont sous le charme et les
gens sont sous le charme à les fortes et
puis pense que les gens pensent qu'un
petit bas de laine
ouais ouais bah j'en ai pas j'aimerais
qui se déconnectent nominés a rendu l a
rendu les 60 millions dont mais c'est
vrai la justice vous avez pu
sérieusement vous regrettez pas fait
part dès que 60 millions en amérique du
sud
on n'est pas ce que ça valait la peine
j'ai sorti mes frégates la preuve elles
sortent moi c'est quand même à la
taïwanaise du gilet pare balles avec
tous les risques que cela comporte et en
péril en ciel pour ça j'ai fait plein de
choses et gérante de 60 millions quoi je
serais heureux voilà les 68 ans vous me
reprochez prenez les je vous le donne ce
que savait pas c'est que le fisc allait
me demander 70 ces lacs
excusez moi que oui mais ce jour là le
jour où vous rendez les 60 millions il
n'y a pas un avocat qui fait signer à la
justice un papier comme quoi c'est pour
solde de tout compte demander 100
millions de mort et garantit
mais c'est mal 1-2 dans chaque individu
dans chaque individu il ya un
justiciable et un contribuable
le contribuable il s'est mis decker chez
clair avec eux j'ai rendu c'est bien il
me le reprocher voilà prenez le terminer
mais le justiciable non et comme c'est
de l'argent que j'avais en gagner et que
j'avais laissé en suisse que gérait pas
rentrer en france
et pour cause je leur entrée en france
je rentrais 60 millions la france me
disait vous avez gagné comment les
frégates à taïwan avec le secret défense
ce sera même pas le déclarer en france
donc c'est vrai que fiscalement je suis
coupable mais je l'ait rendu à la
justice et le fisc lui me dit maintenant
payer 70 millions avec les arriérés vous
pensé des fois sérieusement n'y a pas ou
quand c'est des fous pour y être en
amérique du sud avec 60 millions
non non à l'amérique du nord non en
allemagne 130 me manqueriez de là à
dessein par foyer le câble
bien est vrai que sin de viège en cours
vous avez connu des eaux vous avez connu
des bas c'est l'unité oui surtout pour
le meilleur
[Musique]
christine alors votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
voilà c'est terrible ce que je vous dis
oui je vais être très sincère roland
dumas
ah c'est beau c'est terrible au départ
c'était une mission c'est un service
commandé
c'est un peu comme nous affirment
américains votre mission libyenne avons
aussi bien sur les services n'irai
jamais sans ses potagers 10 ans de ma
vie accepta pas sûr mais surtout des
doutes donc roland dumas plus belles
histoires d'amour landu la pire histoire
d'amour non j'ai pas le pire mois votre
meilleur souvenir avec roland dumas la
levrette à istanbul rage
c'est dans les eaux
c'est dans le livre d'or
je n'invente rien dire et ne connaît non
sérieux un week-end au cap ferret à un
week-end à capturer le pire souvenir et
collants dumas bacchantes et je sais pas
si c'est comme quand tu nous avais c'est
en plein hiver dans ma chambre j'ai fait
du mal et c'est en plein hiver mais sans
parler bien la chanson parce que ça te
la chanson tout de suite ça fixe le plus
beau cadeau qu'on vous ait fait le plus
beau cadeau comme effet je crois que
c'est c'est ce qu'a fait mon avocate
pour me défendre
sophie sa photo était le pire cadeau
qu'on vous ait fait passer 60 me ronge
imagine le pire cadeau c'est de m'avoir
engagé chez elle c'est clair de m'avoir
donné ce travail tôt rappelle tous ces
problèmes chez total je te laisse la
plus belle surprise de votre vie ballet
point elf parce que quand même
une housse de couette on peut le dire
housse de couette trousse à outils tels
que d'autres chefs
ouais maintenant ça sert à rien la plus
belle surprise les plus belles seront
non choix sans mes deux fils les plus
beaux et lalbenque ados du monde d'hier
surprise de votre rue
la pire eva joly les geordies james key
où est la justice française s'est même
pas elles l ont fait ce qu'elles ont pu
sais c'est c'est d'avoir découvert ce
qu'est ce qui est vraiment notre
république notre vème république je
crois que ça c'est une surprise dans ce
long métrage mal marine les gens se
rendent compte là on vous écoutant votre
plus grande qualité là par la franchise
bien sûr le courage votre pierre défaut
la naïveté je viens des billets
c'est vraiment sérieux et naïveté alors
dans la vallée des fées des trucs dont
on attendait
couleurs vous avez l'esprit mal tourné
ça devient impossible de bosser c'est
trop confiance alors je vous ai fait
confiance aussi la première fois que
j'ai dû remarquer vous êtes pas trompés
beaucoup
la preuve regardez ogeret 1 la meilleure
façon pour vous draguez à part l'argent
bien sûr
c'est pas la meilleure la rumeur roland
dumas n'a dragué sans argent la
meilleure façon la meilleure façon pour
me draguer chanter ouais
j'emploie des truites aïn beïda ailleurs
si une faille du launcher forêt fort uba
mbaye et jetant des modems gamestop ou
design du cerveau dit là où nichent
forêt les faux nom j'écris pas
non vraiment en ses chances en sauveur
la meilleure façon de vous draguez c'est
de chanter j'aime le prouver fait qu'il
ya pire façon pour vous draguez de me
mentir à meilleur endroit pour faire
l'amour
moi c'est les frégates
le pire endroit donc à la mort pire
endroit de fer blanc un porte-avions
non je n'ai pas jamais pensé au pire en
noir la banque est bien ajouter bien
pour faire la main plus c'est moche et
mieux c'est nous a voulu dire une xsara
picasso ça peut vous vous excitez la
meilleure façon de mourir d'un seul coup
d'un seul coup sans souffrir en dormant
au volant d'une bagnole à 250
quand il veut qu'on voit pas venir le
tout c'est que ça arrive et ça aille
très vite qu'on n'en parle plus d'accord
comme ça ils prennent des notes là hélas
la prime tower centaure c'est quoi ça
tient la route
s
alors christine vous savez que vous êtes
devenu une star nationale et dans toute
la france sur scène les gens parlent de
vous non mais sérieusement vous êtes
devenu vraiment une héroïne de la
modernité c'est le cas d'ailleurs de
tomer sisley le dimanche soir au trévise
il fait un sketch sur vous et pas au
courant d'une radio ya pas longtemps et
je suis tombé sur le nouveau single de
christine deviers joncour mais denis
celui-ci de les encourager à roland
dumas les frégates ben sassi
en d3 pour avoir des cd vierges pas cher
à taïwan sur des connaisseurs de prison
elle fait un album
moi j'ai bien écouté l'album à mon avis
va retourner en prison mais par son
épaule et sans déconner si tu fais le
plein trois fois chez dos d'âne qui
doivent céder gratuitement
[Musique]
certes les facettes parfois facilement
parce que elle sort un cd à la crise -
telus fournira la vie dans la république
4 janvier le web très intéressant a
touché des millions et des millions et
des millions pour coucher avec des mecs
qui mais ça c'était la belle époque un
expert en ce moment il va arriver
redescendu à 15 euros
il paraît qu'elle travaille sur un
nouveau livre là ça va s'appeler la
[__] de la place publique
les ime
[Musique]
visu
c'est chiant séduit-elle je te jure
tu fous le discours l'artillerie c'est
mon avis hein si je trouve que ça fait
pas une bonne promo c'est moins joli que
la vitesse normale je le dis depuis le
début
et john et jenny le vide et je voudrais
pas que ça devienne une habitude
josiane balasko ray christine
deviers-joncour moi j'ai eu milla
jovovich et maria pacôme l'an dernier à
maria pacôme j'ai demandé s'il est bien
supporté la canicule est méchant joue en
trip
j'accueille maintenant mariane pearl
[Musique]
allez
et
[Musique]
mariane pearl bonsoir j'ai 36 ans vous
êtes française veuve de daniel pearl
journaliste au wall street journal qui a
été enlevé et assassiné par les
islamistes il ya presque deux ans à
karachi alors qu'il enquêtait sur les
filières du terrorisme au pakistan
bernard lévy a consacré un livre à votre
mari le livre s'appelle qui a tué daniel
pearl chez grasset alors aujourd'hui
c'est vous qui publié un livre ça
s'appelle un coeur invaincu la vie et la
mort courageuse de mon mari daniel pearl
édité chez plon
alors vous avez rencontré dernier le
pearl votre mari en 1998 dans une fête
vous responsable cette journaliste à rfi
et lui et au wall street journal mais
basé à londres donc il circule un peu en
europe et dans et dans le monde
vous êtes mariés n'ont plus tard c'était
le coup de foudre
on peut dire j'ai rencontré dans une
soirée en face de l'elysée c'était une
soirée d'une amie il était accompagné
d'une jeune femme blonde
je vais pas je m'étais pas rendu compte
à ce moment là qu'ils étaient avec elle
elle faisait de la lingerie féminine je
me souviens et voilà il est reparti avec
elle quand même et puis ok mais quand
même mais on s'est écrit on s'est écrit
là il est temps l'arabie saoudite à ce
moment là il faisait des erreurs enquête
et puis on s'est écrit on a fini par se
voir
oui c'est ça c'est un jour il vous il
vous dit qu'il peut passer à paris en
allant à londres 100 trains arrivent
d'espagne au bon moment donc en fait ils
passent ils voient comment ça se passait
là il faut partir éventuellement si
voilà s'il se trompe de destination il
n'a jamais repris le train pour aller
alors un assemblage un petit peu
étonnant tous les deux parce que vous
votre père et le fils naturel d'un
diamantaire juifs hollandais vous dit en
parlant lui homosexuels peu sympathique
café l'amour une fois avec une femme et
ça a marché
voilà et votre mère cubaine noir avec un
grand père chinois sérieux mais l'ordre
et lui par an juif
sa mère d'irak et son père d'israël
c'est des bonnes bases pour un
journaliste entre scènes de vie
d'ailleurs qu' il était extrêmement
cosmopolite et les journalistes avant
d'être américain avant d'être juif et
c'est un choix vraiment donné voilà
c'est là il avait cette approche là et
c'est comme ça qui est d'ailleurs passé
son temps moyen orient la plupart du
temps dans les pays musulmans et c'est
comme ça qu'on est parti en inde s'est
passé comme ça par le pakistan alors le
pitch du bouquin c'est simple un cessez
votre vie à karachi du jour du du
kidnapping de votre époux donc daniel
pearl le 23 janvier 2002 jusqu'à votre
départ du pakistan le 27 février 2002
alors c'est pas un livre d' enquête vous
vous ne refaites pas encore une fois
l'enquète si votre histoire dans la
tente de connaître le sort réservé à
votre à votre mari et puis vous parlez
de vos vies vous parlez de votre amour
vous l'aimiez énormément alors quand le
bouquin commence vous êtes tous les deux
à karachi
vous travaillez vous travaillez ensemble
vous l'accompagnez souvent annoncé
l'entrée est interdite ensemble beaucoup
et lui aussi
on était ensemble mais là bon ce jour là
comme vous êtes enceinte à l'époque
vous êtes fatigués vous avez des nausées
et vous le laisser partir tout seul à
son rendez-vous ce jour-là est en cause
il ya beaucoup de concours de
circonstances ce genre là donc moi je
crois pas trop à l'idée de destin mais
mais c'est vrai que par exemple des il
ya des mesures de sécurité dans ce genre
de pays on prend pas trop de taxi bon ce
jour-là un taxi-be et bien il ya un
certain nombre de salles de concours de
circonstances qui bon qui ont fait que
le kidnapping a été possible et et que
moi je sois resté en fait derrière c'est
ça surtout si vous aviez été avec lui
est ce que vous pensez que les
islamistes qui l'ont assassiné je dirais
beaucoup plus que ça à découper en
morceaux après l'avoir décapité
est ce que vous croyez qu'il l'aurait
fait quand même je pense que oui je
pense que oui je pense pas qu'on a on
est devant des gens qui auraient acquis
auraient reculé en fait de valeur de 20
le fait que je sois une femme y aura
suffi tandis que mon père était juif par
exemple même enceinte même enceinte même
enceinte alors daniel pearl ce matin la
part seul il fait une enquête sur reed
le type qui avait pris l'avion avec les
chaussures prennent d'explosifs l'homme
se mêlent explosive comme on l'a appelé
il va rencontrer le fameux ghillani il a
rendez vous avec omar sheikh dondon lévy
parle dans son bouquin et c'est vrai que
cette marche est qu au départ comme il a
fait la london school of economics et
pas quelqu'un qui est dans ton peut se
méfier au départ c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement efficace enfin quelqu'un
qu'il ya cette espèce de sac c'est comme
une espèce de terroristes freelance que
je pense avoir fait reprendre un petit
peu la nouvelle génération de
terroristes et des gens qui s'associe à
des opérations précisé ce désastre de
l'an suite lui omar sheikh c'est
quelqu'un effectivement de d3 éduqués
qui ya une vraie perversité en êtes vous
dans 7 à sa façon de faire par exemple à
dany lui envoyer des emails en disant
c'est pas grave si vous voulez pas venir
la prochaine fois quand daniel été
kidnappés il n'a envoyé notre hymne à la
danse on danse on sa boîte en disant
comment s'est passé votre rendez vous
voyez c'est ce que c'est quand même
voilà vicieux a une approche très
vicieuse ontera perverse mais à la fois
avec un budget du génie mal en quoi
alors
la journée se passe vous n'arrivez pas à
le joindre ça vous étonne parce que
d'habitude
vous dites que vous vous appelez toutes
les 90 minutes sur les portes à un
système de sécurité simplement fait de
nous appeler si nous n'étions pas
ensemble de nous appeler toutes les 90
minutes pour aston simple le soir
toujours pas de dany vous êtes dans un
dîner vous vous éloignez et puis vous
commencez à réciter parce que vous êtes
bouddhiste vous récitez namur hinglé kyo
et ça c'est la france ça aide
ça valide et ça m'a aidé énormément
parce que effectivement là toutes les
choses qui sont vraiment des valeurs sur
mon service normal quoi voilà donc le
bouddhisme est une valeur sûre
apparemment c'est vrai alors là vous
appelez le consulat américain et on vous
dit que ça peut attendre le lendemain
matin et on l'a on tombe sur un sur un
pion en fait un qui nous dit non mais
peut-être il a bu peut-être il et je
sais pas où enfin c'est eux qui nous dit
attendez d'eux maintenant effectivement
la leader compte c'est difficile mais
oui c'est à dire que vous en faites vous
savez tout de suite que ça peut être un
accident de bagnols vous vous doutez
quelque chose de plus grave ou comment
c'est même un petit peu à culpabiliser
en vous disant j'aurais jamais dû le
laisser partir tout seul il n'aurait
jamais dû y aller enfin et c est là vous
appeler les parents de votre mari de
dany comme vous l'appelez sa mère qui
s'appelle ruth et elle vous dit cette
phrase fall vous le dis qu'à la fin de
l'entretien téléphonique mais vous vous
ressentez qu'elle y pense depuis le
début elle vous dit est ce que quelqu'un
sait que nous sommes juifs
voilà c'était sa première première
réaction mais moi aussi quand même c'est
ça ouais c'est une zone où bon quand
même en pensant que bon toute cette nuit
là on avait accumulé des informations
sur les gens sur la nature des personnes
qui l'avaient qu'il devait rencontrer
on n'était pas rassurés quand même donc
on est quand même après le 11 septembre
on sait que enfin moi explications avec
al-qaïda et c'est donc la pose la
question quand même elle avait raison a
été de savoir qui c'est que des juifs
que sa mère tout de suite a repéré le 3
perret a repéré le truc et c'est vrai
vous dites qu'au pakistan il ya une
vraie haine
des des juifs et vous avez rencontré un
ancien patron qui s'appelle amis de
goules des services secrets pakistanais
jusqu'en 89 qui vous dit que le jour du
wall trade center en fait tous les juifs
ne sont pas allés travailler ce qui est
une espèce de fantasme de grands circulé
sur internet dans les pays arabes mais
bon les gens croyaient dans leur
ignorance en fait que le mossad avait
organisé toutes ces attaques avec les
4000 juifs qui travaillait au world
trade center n'était pas là ce jour là
ouais voilà donc vous entendez ça de la
bouche d'un d'un dignitaire du but du
canadien qui quand même été on a eu un
entretien d'une heure avec dany donc ils
avaient des arguments intéressants c'est
bien de plausible il avait dirigé les
rails et ça les services secrets
pakistanais pendant un an
bon avec les américains etc et puis sur
des qu'il dise qu'il s'agissait des
juifs est plus viable c'était plus bon
c'était plus c'est plus rationnel mais
là c'est plus rationnel alors vous
finissez par recevoir des photos de
votre mari
combien de jours après le jour de
l'enlèvement 3h03 jouable donc vous
recevez des photos qui confirme
effectivement qu'il a été kidnappé qu'il
est donc vivant mais en même temps qu'il
a un bon mental parce qu'à une photo où
il a influé sur la tempe et en fait on
voit bien la photo d'ailleurs il y là il
a un sourire quoi malgré ça donc vous
vous dites quand même il et il tient bon
quoi ouais je pense qu'il est
dernièrement en fait on a été dans le
même état d'esprit dès le départ à
savoir que je pense qu'on a tous les
deux compris exactement là on se
trouvait et compris ce qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse exactement donc même la
première premières réactions celle à
résister à la peur
voyez donc je pensais ce qu'il a fait
tout de suite c'est ce que j'ai fait
tout de suite
et quand on est effectivement j'ai reçu
des photos bon il avait une photo
effectivement il ya une absolue sur la
tempe et un sourire sur les lèvres
photo xd
quand même je sais ce qu'ils pensent je
sais comment agissez comme un résidu
issu comme un bon mois c'était la même
chose donc j'étais quand même assez
confiant
vous dites en voyant ça finalement on
peut pas s'emparer d'un esprit fort quoi
césaire qu'ils ont beau le tenir
physiquement sous la puissance des armes
son esprit reste reste fort voilà alors
à ce moment là effectivement il ya une
certaine aide internationale qui se met
en place il ya farrakhan le leader de
national islam qui est un mouvement
musulman américain il ya l'émir du qatar
qui était un ami de daniel pearl mohamed
ali cat stevens chanteur des années 60
reconvertir ouais mais d'abord il
absolument et qui s'appelle moossou fils
la maintenance of islam voilà et alors
il n'ya que michael jordan qui refuse à
travers son agent l'attaché de presse
que jordan pas pour des raisons d'image
sans rien enfin bon voilà je leur mets
livre ouais ouais ça y est quand même
une mobilisation des gens les gens sont
unis afin se sont réunis à l'idéal it
bon il dit est innocent cette saison et
tout le monde le savait mais donc même
les gens qui d'ailleurs qu'ils ont
capturé je pense ça et c'est vraiment
dans le monde islamique serait notamment
les gens se sont mobilisés on va envoyer
des beaux messages à l'air d'être très
beau message
bon je pense que là on était quand même
au delà de la communication
fonctionnaient et puis arrive la
nouvelle de la mort de dany
vous écrivez un cri d'animal quand la
mâchoire métallique du piège se referme
sur la bâtir que quand vous avez la
preuve qu'il est qu'il est mort vous
hurlez tu hurles parce que j'ai mal
parce que ça fait ça ça fait mal
oui parce qu'on a passé cinq semaines a
en fait une espèce de résistance mentale
très très très très fort donc et une
réaction comme ça d'abord je mens
évidemment je crie parce que parce qu'il
fallait sortir qui parce qu'on n'a rien
on n'a rien sorti aucun d'entre nous n'a
laissé aucune émotion filtré pendant
plusieurs pendant toutes ces semaines
ensuite je me souviens avoir d'être
emparé d'un équipe qu'il faut laisser
revenir aux commandes d'air france a
gagné 47 à ak 47 et des réactions comme
ça mais en réalité
quand même quand j'ai les personnes qui
m'ont raconté ce qu'ils ont vu et pour
gagner commente-il et comment il est
mort m'ont donné en fait tout de suite
ce d'état et qu'il donne dans la vidéo
qui en fait on lui pose des questions
avant de le tuer et à ce détail en fait
concerner son grand père enfin ce une
rue en israël qui porte le nom de son
grand-père et nager compris que cette
même attitude qui défendra qu'il avait
dans les photos il avait conservé jusqu
alors et c'est là que j'ai su que qu'il
fallait je reste debout moi même parce
que singer invalidé en fait sont sa
défiance voilà par rapport aux tendances
alors vous dites évidemment quand vous
apprenez ça vous avez vous frapper la
tête contre les murs de la salle de
bains mais c'est normal que cette
enceinte ça c'est une situation
absolument intenable et et vous dites
mais comment vous savez qu'il est mort
et on vous dit il ya une vidéo et
ensuite vous dites mais enfin il ya vous
avez aucun doute sur sa mort et on vous
dit non il a été décapité quoi ça c est
heureusement je dirais comme vous êtes
bouddhiste vous pensez au cycle de la
vie vous pensez que la mort n'est pas
une fin et que tout ça est cyclique et
ça vous aide aussi à ce moment-là ça
m'aide à ce moment là mais je pense que
c'est surtout l'année bouddhisme en fait
n'a amené tout de suite la clairvoyance
surtout avant tout c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas une vue de l'esprit non plus
quoi sert on peut pas annoncer que
moment là c'est trop extrêmes donc
c'était plus si vous voulez à ce moment
là il ya quand même quelque chose de
très intime qui se passait et je pense
que tu arrives à un moment à ce moment à
ce moment là où j'avais plus peur de la
mort d'un bon donc comme je dis dans le
livre il ya toutes les théories sur bons
qui sont passés avant moi réincarnation
paradis je sais pas quoi en faire et c
est là je me suis rendu compte que que
que à travers en tuant dany les gens qui
l'avaient tué espérer moi me tuer moi et
puis notre enfant et puis tous les gens
qui s'identifient à lui est la seule
véritable réaction par rapport au
terrorisme c'est pas à la guerre puisque
toute façon sur leur terrain on peut pas
je peux pas les combattre ouais
mais c'était c'était c'était du vivant
et de vivre en plus heureuse donc à ce
moment là ça me paraissait quand même
dire impossible mais mais je me suis
relevé je les fais ouais alors
évidemment web et la tv
alors la question pourquoi daniel pearl
at il été assassiné alors pour bernard
henri lévy dans son bouquin il avait
découvert des liens entre les islamistes
et le programme nucléaire pakistanais
est ce que c'est avéré ça
je sais pas donc la thèse de bernard
henri lévy est intéressante elle est
possible et plausible
maintenant il est quand même aussi
possible qu'on les tue et simplement
parce qu'on voulait décourager tous les
journalistes d'investigation qui était
sur place parce que quand même ça
commençait à devenir délicat parce qu'il
était juif
là ça suffit dans ce genre de deux pays
ou parce qu'ils étaient américains
bon c'est je ne sais pas encore une
autre théorie aussi c'est que un
ordinateur bourré de secret d'al-qaïda
avait été trouvée par les journalistes
du wall street journal
et cet ordinateur avait été livrée ce
qui est assez rare d'ailleurs à la cia
et quand daniel pearl votre mari avait
appris ça et il vous dit baby on va
avoir des ennuis quand même donc il
savait quand même que le wall street
journal seraient particulièrement visées
par ces gens là ne serait ce que je vois
ce journal trouve cet ordinateur
contenait 1700 dossier avec des vidéos
etc qui reprenaient leurs puces le le
trajet d'un bridge ou [__] donc sur
lequel année enquêtait et de votre
journal bon et c'est normal si vous
voulez qu'ils ont retrouvé un ordinateur
comme celui là il peut sauver des
attaques et des vies bon vous pouvez
donner la stilla et pouvait pas le faire
rendre public à l'horizon publié des
articles et que saclay claironné ça et
vous vous passez votre temps à prouver
aux gens fin a essayé de dire aux gens
vous n'êtes pas des espions
quand même oui on était en danger tout
est la raison finalement alors vous êtes
vous dit vous êtes contre la peine de
mort j'imagine et non voilà bouddhiste
nareit je pense que dans le bouddhisme
que je pratique et j'ai déjà lu un texte
souvent fait on me disait pour par
rapport aux gens qui fabriqué la bombe
nucléaire que ces gens là méritait la
mort donc par rapport à vendre un chèque
par exemple qui a été condamné à mort en
tout cas toujours pas été exécuté
ok donc son procès c'est cette personne
là bon je vais pas vous dire qu'elles
méritent de vivre je vais pas vous dire
qu'elle est excusable il est conscient
de ce qu'il fait en marche et quand même
c'est quelqu'un de
on pourrait mettre en prison à
perpétuité pour un être présentes erp et
8 et mais je pense que enfin bon pour
moi ce qui se comptait le plus c'était
bon de george bush par exemple la
demande est ce que vous voulez des alors
qu'il soit extradé aux états unis
bon pour moi ce qui comptait c'est que
le pakistan le mettre à mort est ce que
c'est un c'est une déclaration politique
ouais délicat jours mais un engagement
dans tous les cas l'envié de faire le
rabat la peine de mort pour omar sheikh
en tous les cas c'est clair mais quand
on lit votre livre il ya un mirage les
miennes arriver à dépasser
vous dites je me bats pour que mes
sentiments soient supérieurs mais
réaction tiens peut pas avoir une
réaction comme ça bestiale mais essayer
de dépasser d'en faire une histoire un
peu symbolique quoi là à la haine en
fait c'est le sera début de la paralysie
et la baleine en fait nan apporte aucune
aucune possibilité d'action d'abord
aucune possibilité d'avenir
bon on a quand même un enfant et en plus
si vous voulez c'était le but recherché
c'est tellement ccsa l'accueil d'arras
et fomenté la haine créé un à la surface
entre les civilisations
le premier la première résistance et
celle ci en fait elle a peur puis line
ouais c'est je ne fais que résister au
terrorisme j'essaie de transformer le
paludisme j'adore le bouddhisme vous et
c'est sûr mais le calvaire de votre mari
en victoire c'est ça non lui la victoire
lui là c'était bien mais mais mais si
moi je suis si lui l'a gagnée je pense
maman quoi mais si moi je suis quand
même là pour valider sa victoire c'est à
travers notre enfant à travers un jeu
fait quoi c'est ça vous n'avez pas perdu
le sourire dany vous disais toujours
nous allons devenir chauve gros et vieux
mais tu n'as pas le droit de perdre ce
sourire et voulait pas perdre et malgré
tout malgré les épreuves que vous
affrontez depuis alors effectivement on
parle de cet enfant quand dany a été
assassiné vous étiez enceinte
il s'appelle adam il a aujourd'hui 17
mois et vous dites en barrant lui c'est
le bébé universelle c'est vrai il a tous
les sens mélanger je crois que c'est
vraiment un
il a très bien si vous n'aviez pas été
enceintes à la mort de daniel pearl est
ce que vous seriez suicider je ne pense
pas je me serais suicidé je pense que
j'aurais été j'aurais fait quelque chose
je me sens pas tuer moi même je pense
que j'aurais peut-être je sais pas fait
quelque chose c'est facile d'en face il
ya déjà beaucoup d'armes dans le coin
j'en fais quelque chose de peut-être de
désespérer de l'être un geste désespéré
je sais rien je sais pas si c'est plus
mon histoire là je sais pas vous donner
un bon état
[Musique]
la vie et la mort pour ajustement marie
danielle blain
non
[Musique]
sacrée bonne femme à femme tu as vu ce
soir on a quelques fans force là
dominique loiseau mariane pearl rappel
des maires de chômage et les mères
courage absolument
et maintenant voici jean rugby
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lahaye bonsoir bonsoir kerry
donné ses consignes de lille jean ping
laurent baffie
je connais moins bien pourtant il vous
torche au tennis assez régulièrement y
est tu t'es vente est déjà passé dans la
fraise c'est ma bête noire aïe d'accord
ouais il a jamais gagné à l'est et
pourtant il sait pas jouer je peux le
dire
c'est vrai c'est que c'est comme moi je
fais tourner au ballet s'est entraîné
quatre heures par jour deux ans je vais
tuer et prend deux roues de bicyclette
pas tout à fait pas tout à fait mais bon
elle a douché milliers jusqu'à rennes
mais que l'attention mais pense qu'à ça
il est super bien les plaisirs d'une
compensation aux antilles et en sait
combien par carte
combien de nos médias la caisse il
rappelle des petites sommes
le travail des petites sonne bien alors
jean luc lahaye débarquer moi papa
chanteur appelle moi brando et voilà
didier
[Musique]
simplement très vite
je t'ai
oui
nouveau
hollow
je suis 3
[Musique]
je suis prêt
dir
dans un an
il y
la page
armand tout ça
là
[Musique]
la vie bière de
papa chanteur
[Musique]
et que j'aurai
gelée
il y a
rennes
ul
mais
[Musique]
et loin
l'homme était là qu'est mois
que m
[Musique]
viré de
donné la foi qui
mais moi
que chez nous
m
beaucoup tâtonné
la jolie jen
[Applaudissements]
jean luc lahaye donc avant de parler de
votre nouveau disque
jean luc lahaye jouer qu'on revienne sur
une affaire qui a défrayé la chronique
vous aussi un petit peu comme christine
de les gens courent la fermeture de
votre boîte de nuit depuis six mois et
sa réouverture
comme une bonne nouvelle il leur
fermeture depuis 20 minutes ça vient le
temps des salles le 19 novembre
alors voilà donc la boîte s'appelle 287
c'est pas loin d'ici d'ailleurs c'est
s'est plaint de saint denis
arias une vaste opération de police
alors à cause de trafic de drogue de
violence des vigiles sur les clients et
de détention d'armes blanches et d'armes
à feu attendait puisque quelqu'un qui a
traversé hors des passages cloutés mais
ça c'est pas dans le procès verbal il va
s'expliquer non alors en effet il ya une
opération il ya six mois
voilà c'était sur commission rogatoire à
propos de travail illicite savoir
travail dc220 tard pour chanter et en
effet violence de vigiles sur certaines
places c'est vrai mais c'est vrai ça la
drogue la violence avec liant la drogue
c'est absolument faux absolument faux il
a été trouvé aucune trace de drogue non
287 nanya lance pas de violence humaine
j'aurais également et que c'était quoi
après les pubs si si quelques denrées
violence des dix vigiles sur les clients
et est aussi détention d'armes blanches
et d'armes blanches
c'est faux armes à feu donc tout est
faux nom mais en vérité je crois que
tout le monde a lu un jour un certain
journal très parisien le parisien deux
parisiennes le par exemple noté un
journaliste nommé stéphane boucher oui
c'est fade mouche et bien là qui
d'ailleurs s'acharne sur johnny
également oui c'est vrai ils s'intégrer
commencé au chômage mais à mon avis
c'est un journaliste qui est couteau aux
portes aux analyses qui rentrent pas
dans les boîtes aux lettres des gens lui
c'est quand même pas stéphane boucher
qui a envoyé les flics aux 296 du tout
mais stéphane duchêne me persécuter
depuis pas mal de temps par un appui
certain nombre de mois à chaque fois
qu'il y avait un événement aubervilliers
entre un fait mineur n'importe quoi la
sphère été ramené à jean luc lahaye du
287 1 en effet un type qui traverse en
dehors des clous vols à la roulotte un
violent main armée n'importe quoi mais
bon ça veut dire que c'est lui qui
aurait mis la puce à l'oreille au coeur
il a participé à la halle à monter la
pression à la diabolisation du lieu en
effet et d'ailleurs ils ont largement
rajouter à tel point que il y a quelques
semaines il y avait encore une demi page
sur moi dans ce ce magasin ce journal
c'est énorme de mes pages au niveau de
l'année très sympathique d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je trouve que il est très
sympathique puisqu'il parlement assez
régulièrement faudrait que lui envoie
des photos assez récente
c'est la seule chose que je puisse faire
de bien éventuellement si je le
rencontre
jour de le saluer lui dire voilà est-ce
que vous voulez que je vous annonce
quelque chose de réel un jour je vais te
mettre un bourre-pif aussi par jean-luc
sérieusement est-ce qu'on a fermé cette
boîte uniquement à cause de boucher
pendant six mois
non c'est à cause de lui il ya une
intervention de police à la suite de
cette intervention il a été relevé un
certain nombre de l'infraction
concernant les primes non déclarées aux
salariés et en effet il y avait des
plaintes concernant le service d'ordre
ce depuis un an et demi et vous accusez
aussi un autre patron de boîte de nuit
parisien qui m'arrêtent il vous en
venant pas du tout ça cette bouche
égalise
oui oui c'est marrant ils sont quand
même nom mais des idées mais je crois
que six rencontres jeunes il lui va
avoir du souci à ce faire j'ai pas du
tout
donc voilà donc la boîte a été quand
même ferait pendant six mois c'est un
accident un accident industriel
ouais ouais bah oui puisqu'il faut payer
tout le monde les salariés les charges
two way et on rentre pas un centime de
trésorerie
ouais mais moi je reste sur un non dit
je comprends pas pourquoi on ferme cet
établissement alors que je n'y suis pour
rien ouais a ses revers on me dit mais
s'il vient de rouvrir
est ce que c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon site
ce 1/4 de bons clients voilà on donne
des cartes de nos clients utilisent non
non non je suis là avec cette carte à
puce et moi qui n'ont pas que je n'aime
pas moustier car c'est un copain et je
l'apprécié mais je ne lui ai jamais
donné physiquement cette carte tu
n'étais pas là mais les valides fêté au
québec et qui distribue les cartes
pendant que c'est pas là sans déconner
c'est le monsieur au noir là je pense
que c'est moi que distribuer cartes
ballon rond pourquoi il faut voter si
c'est valable ou pas - euros 50 m qui
signe une carte de bons clients c'est
génial l'employeur procède mise au mur
un truc à des gardes devant clients
peuvent venir quand ils veulent juste il
était passé comme ça je veux quand même
offre ça moi je viens nous autres très
très bien vous venez parler de votre
livre oui tout à fait l'oeuvre qui sera
nommé
ça vous a pas de problème vous venez
quand vous voulez c'est sympa alors
c'est jean luc lahaye
c'est vrai que j'étais protégé par un
juge d'instruction qui est en prison
aujourd'hui pour trafic d influence faut
aller tout est faux ce soir ce soir
ce soir vous êtes dans une stratégie
mais elle m'appelle devient gens qu au
début non aujourd'hui je suis un des
quotidiens sur le dos il a réalisé à moi
j'ai le monde
tu as eu d'alerté c'est vrai oui puis un
beau jour on se rend compte qu'on me
disait la vérité quant à l'achat alors
j'en ai non mais sérieux donc tout tout
tout est faux là il y avait drogué mais
pas de violence drogue avait pas d'armes
je ne vous n'êtes pas protégé par un
juge qui est mis en vous voulez parler
de jean louis voirain du procureur jean
lui voir que je connais en effet comme
tous les gens qui ont des débits des
licences iv sur aubervilliers
ouais parce que c'est l interlocuteur au
tribunal au tribunal où je le
connaissais et je les ai rencontrés
quelques fois on fait les mêmes venez à
mon anniversaire lorsque j'ai donné un
concert de 8,7 l'année dernière au même
titre que 500 invités ouais on ne vous a
jamais il faisait jamais protégé non il
m'a jamais protégé m'a prodigué quelques
bons conseils
lorsque je basculais du dîner spectacle
à la discothèque
ouais et c'est tout c'est le tandem
chèque ou alors je vais vous dénoncez
beaucoup de choses je vais lancer une
enquête policière fait en dépit du bon
sens un an noncé encore stéphane boucher
le cdc était sans pitié cdc mois cdc
vont donc c'est pas vrai vous avez
jamais dénoncé une enquête policière
fait en dépit du bon sens pas du tout
c'était un article ça dans vsd
je le dis si les babouches et alors
c'est pas boucher non mais ça c'était
moche il a pas des parts dans vsd
vous dénoncez une exploitation
médiatique contraire à toute déontologie
ça oui c'est bouché la wii mais toujours
bah oui il écrit il écrira un truc à
notre ami bush et s'ils voulaient
devenir la semaine prochaine venez venez
vous répondre puisque maintenant je
serai présent sais pas si tu veux tu as
une carte de conversion et johnny sera
là aussi avec les miens je dirais non
c'est pas porter plainte et j'aurais pu
le faire
ouais c'est pas dans ma philosophie je
porte jamais plaint très je règle les
choses différemment
comment quand je vois l'individu bien
quand je vois l'individu qui me nuit
peut prendre une part dans la tête je
suis moi à prise rapide
non mais c'est qu'une balade sur la
scène moi je supporte pas je prends pas
plein voilà est ce que est ce que dans
toute cette histoire comme un petit peu
difficile parce que quand même une boîte
préféré pendant six mois c'est ce qu'il
n'y a pas eu des bons moments défouloir
par les terribles
sinon il portera pas plainte mais parce
que terminant site aura plus de bras
alors est ce que est ce que sérieusement
est-ce que nicolas sarkozy vous a aidé
pas du tout il manie et dénis nuit j'ai
il est en dehors de toute chose je pense
que c'était vous avez quand la boîte a
été fermée vous avez cherché à le
joindre à des tounes absolue bon je
l'avais vu auparavant c'est encore une
invention tout à fait encore encore un
mensonge éhonté de ce journaliste
boucher
bush est exactement vous voyez et
christine quand même qu' il n'y a pas
que vous quelle est désormais la justice
mais vous pouvez interroger d'ailleurs
le ministre intérieur
oui et vous confirmera que j'ai jamais
bien tenté nord a rendez-vous en
revanche il ya quelqu'un que vous
connaissez c'est jacques chirac qui
j'avais longtemps que vous le connaissez
il est venu au 287 pendant la campagne
de 2002
il me sens très bien et est en chine
certains c'était une nuit il appellerait
c'était une fête de l'internet
tout à fait il est venu faire un meeting
et dialoguer en direct avec les autres
les internautes ouais mais vous le
connaissez de longue date et je le
crains que lang septième tir ils lui ont
suggéré le luron qui avait représenté ya
22 ans est quand même très proche
absolument je très proche non mais c'est
quelqu'un pour qui j'ai beaucoup de
défauts génétiques c'est un ami de
longue date
oui un ami de longue date en effet parce
que et lui dit je ne connais pas cet
individu il ya quand même un problème
moi je pense pas qu'il dirait ça je
pourrais celle a déclaré le 20 septembre
[Musique]
non non d'accord donc voila quoi donc
chirac vous l'avais appelé non non mais
pourquoi leur plaît pas ce que je vais
vous dire un truc moi si on me fermer ma
boîte pendant six mois j'appellerai un
ami de longue date
non non je pense qu'il n'a rien à voir
dans cette opération je veux il a appelé
d'autres des fonctions qui n'ont jeu non
non j'ai appelé personne j'ai pas de
relation j'ai pas un tel ton nom sur les
plaques des motos et a pas de relation
pour moi pour un coût je suis parent de
deux motards de paris pratique assez
alors ghosn est marraine un fait gaffe
la marraine de la marraine et bernadette
chirac et je suis parrain depuis très
très longtemps à tuer puisque attention
ils n'ont rien à voir c'est une passion
je suis un motard est bien menée c'est
une passion étaient des je pense qu'elle
aime la moto
si ce que tu connais drucker j'aime bien
sûr c'est un vrai gentil je connais pas
intimement comme vous non parce que moi
je pense qu'il est vraiment sympa
d'accueillir oui oui non je fais pivot
brand est pourquoi il a arrêté pivot il
en avait marre vraiment de bouquins je
suis pas au courant
les pivots c'est pas un scoop mais
l'arj21 qu'il est passé aux caisses qui
devient jean claude bourret en a aucune
c'est maintenant je suis pas de la tour
de contrôle du paf c'est qui coalise
danièle gilbert daniel jaco newey voilà
ces données il ya des connivences je
connais je connais laurent baffie il est
hors jeu concédant il ya un truc quand
même il ya sur votre cd il ya une
reprise que vous avez fait de souquet
l'étoile suis jeune et oui et c'est vrai
qu'en bispo je crois en regardant en
regardant votre vie on se demande ce
serait des fois il faisait planer sur
une drôle des touareg mais comme dirait
stéphane boucher j'ai un destin
sulfureux
ouais non c'est vrai vous avez déclaré
je suis sorti de la das pour aller en
prison
c'est tout un destin qui est résumé en
quelques mots la légende de jean luc
lahaye on va on va là raconte évidemment
il ya la date donc laisser parler vous
avez fait un bouquin qui s'appelle sans
famille qui s'est vendu à 1,3 million
d'exemplaires je souhaite ça a beaucoup
de potes à tous les écrivains à tous les
écrivains ensuite bombe à votre mère
très très difficile la vie avec votre
mère votre mère distribuer des bibles
dans le métro elle forcé les gens à
s'agenouiller alors quand on se dit mais
pourquoi c'est qu'on fait votre mère
s'était jeté dans la seine pour se
suicider de la vaisselle
voilà et ya une bonne soeur incroyable
une bonne soeur qui en voyant ça a
plongé une bonne soeur et un passant un
âge bien les bonnes soeurs on se rend
pas là avec leur avec la cornette même
et c est donc à ce moment là votre mère
a été recueilli par cette bonne soeur
qui l'a envoyé dans le périgord dans un
couvent où elle venir un peu toc et de
la religion catholique on peut dire oui
oui demain ma mère continue à vivante
elle est dans un établissement
spécialisé
et dès qu'elle peut sortir va prêcher
dans la rue partout moi je me souviens
elle venait me chercher à la dass
quelquefois elle avait un filet garni
avec me souviens baguette de pain un lit
de limonade
si l adorer sage progrès et un paquet de
bible distribué dans l'après-midi le
métro elle tenait vraiment très fort et
regarder les gens choisissait ses
victimes me souviens d'un monsieur qui
disait sur journal va tranquillement à
lui arracher le journal ce qu'ils
voulaient pas d'écouter à eux dit vous
êtes un pêcheur le gars a dit quoi que
c'est pourquoi mettez-vous à genoux
mettez-vous à genoux demandé pardon à
dieu de galles s'est mis à genoux parce
qu'il a eu peur et a faim il l'a béni à
la sortie de l'eau bénite comme ça l'ue
appelle lui a donné une bible dit lisez
sa liste ça c'est votre sauveur c'est la
portion verte avaler sûreté avec elle le
ghana la regarder comme ça moi j'avais
honte
et puis elle a distribué dans le métro
et ses jours à la casse et des beats
parce qu'on voulait l'interdire faire
bon c'était un vous dit vous dites et en
parlant d'elle qu'elle a été irradié par
la religion ça veut tout dire et alors
très bizarre c'est quand elle venait
vous voir à la dass es vous apportez
toujours des oeufs de pâques par exemple
oui quel que soit le jour de l'ag
vous êtes bien renseigné c'est vrai
c'est vrai on a vu la dass on a vu votre
mère votre beau-père achour alcoolique
et méchant ce qui fait que vous
retournez à la dass finalement on
préfère encore être à la dass que qu'à
la maison tellement il est tellement
désagréable et enfin après 73 familles
d'accueil
c'est beaucoup
quelques fois j'en faisais une dans la
journée un voire deux bras en l'air
après 73 familles d'accueil avec 200
balles vous démarrez dans la ville jean
luc lahaye et là il ya une scène assez
dur parce que je pense à stevie wonder
qui racontent la même chose c'est que
vous aviez pas de blé vous manger des
haricots verts à même la boîte faisait
chauffer la boîte sur le sur le gaz avec
un gant avec un gant de toilette
oui tout à fait oui j'ai fait ça pendant
des années ouais c'est pas un problème
ouais oui la ligne ne la peña rico il
n'y a pas de problème j'ai envie
d'ouvrir des boîtes quoi merci mais ça
c'est quand je m'éclatais parce que les
soirs de les soirs de disette
je mangeais à même les rayons des
supermarchés ouais ça a duré combien
deux trois ans ouais voilà alors ça
c'est l'époque des petits boulots à un
moment vous êtes gardes du corps et
chauffeur pour zizi jeanmaire et roland
petit sans avoir de permis de conduire
je n'avais pas le permis
c'est fort bas où je ne sais pas si
c'est fort mais n'ont pas demandé
ouais je n'ai pas présenté
j'avais je conduisais une alfa romeo une
rolls enfin je n'avais pas droit à la
roche mais un soir j'ai prise et elle a
fini place du tertre dans un mur j'étais
avec plein de potes dedans
et là jean luc l'avez-vous rencontré
gérard pedro restaurateurs de son état
qui va devenir votre votre producteur
peu après vous rencontrez dalida qui
vous loue le premier étage de sa maison
pendant trois mois je me demande
toujours bon je vous laisse j'ai
l'esprit mal tourné mais quand on est le
garde du corps de roland petit quand on
loue le premier étage de la maison de
dalida
est-ce que ça s'arrête à des rapports
professionnels ou non je sais pas ce qui
concerne roland petit je vous rassure
tout de suite et non plus non non non tu
sais que hollande au xixe le clip de oui
thierry rolando et le délicat donc que
vous louez le premier étage de sa maison
à montmartre le dernier étage par étage
de dalida et la nuit vous descendez à
peu de la cave pour vider le frigo
non david agression david hâle est rude
il est censé passer avec david abel
s'est rien passé et c'était une amie ah
bon parce que nous on pensait que la
chanson était à cause de 18 ans il court
enfants ou de comètes
quelle belle chanson quelle belle
chanson pascal sevran et joyeux oui et
dalida m a loué le dernier étage sa
maison parce qu'elle avait peur à
l'habiter seul jour saison assez pour ça
et moi et moi je j'étais là c'était
rassurant porte quelqu'un et ça marche
allez en plus je terminais ses frigos en
effet voilà un mot week-end parce
qu'elle partait en corse tous les
week-ends et elle faisait des quantités
industrielles le repas pour des amis qui
venaient ou pas et fallait terminer moi
je montais tous à la maison et que les
potes
voilà voilà donc j'ai une anecdote avec
chéri de confiance et par avance d par
avance mais vas-y
j'ai rencontré en effet jacques chirac
qui m'avait été présenté par thierry le
luron quand que tu es lui même n'avait
été présentée par jean jacques debout
voilà qui est maintenant sorti de prison
je crois que tout est clair on peut
compter et qui est d'ailleurs était dans
une cellule voisine de jean louis
voirain boire ça va comme colin farrell
sirven cette émission quoi que c'est
alfatières vin café de 4 donnée par un
manche et à jean jacques debout les
hawks chinois insoupçonnées bras volant
alors on continue les légendes de jean
luc lahaye donc après dalida il ya les
premiers tubes
femmes
comme on le dit
je t'aime
alors après tout le monde connaît
l'histoire de la fondation la fameuse
fonda inauguré par françois mitterrand
il ne fréquente que des présents dans le
public
inauguré par françois mitterrand au baby
foot à la panda fait voilà c'était
d'ailleurs un moment très bon jour parce
que l'histoire du baby foot n'était pas
prévu dans le parcours du problème et à
un moment il voit le baby foot il ya
c'est un baby foot jeux tv en effet
monsieur le président une partie il dit
volontiers je m'installe ici mais à côté
de moi déjà ouais donc je dis non c'est
par ici monsieur le président et là j'ai
été incroyable il a pris les joueurs par
les têtes
ah oui mais bon j'ai des enseignes le
président on prend par là il nous a
gouverné pendant quatorze noms mais bon
bon alors voilà donc mitterrand après
chirac le baby-foot la fonda et ensuite
tf1 s'est passé muluzi qui vous présente
jean luc lahaye à monsieur francis
bouygues pour faire une émission qui
s'appelle la haie d'honneur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donnez là
qui
alors un an plus tard il faut bien c'est
fini à 1 le générique était débarqué
mois donc effectivement ça va pas durer
très très longtemps
alors vous avez été viré de tf1 jean luc
lahaye au bout d'un an
quand patrick sabatier est revenu parce
que patrick sabatier des parties sur
l'a5
quand il revient à tf1 vous êtes viré
pour faire de la place qua non je ne
sais pas si c'est cette relation je suis
pas ça non je ne crois pas que ce soit
bien donc
après la traversée du désert j'avais eu
une traversée du désert
voilà personne vous appelle plus sauf
comme quoi tu vas le showbiz c'est pas
juste que des [__] sauf michel
drucker c'est vraiment sympa grâce à
elle
non il m'a appelé il a fait rodial
peut-être non non non mais la bouche est
aussi un nom mais m'a jamais appelé gma
bien qu'ils m'appellent michel drucker
m'a appelé un soir c'est le sort
d'anniversaire 23 décembre d'ailleurs je
pensais qu'il allait me souhaiter bon
anniversaire à la clé pour proposer de
se rencontrer une tête et un coup de fil
spontanée et tenter de me secouer de mai
revient il faut faire un album qu'est ce
que tu fous c'est pas possible cette
situation mais qu'est ce que tu as côté
dépressif gênant mais j'avais très bien
mais j'étais pas dans un camp suite
logique gérard lenorman michel drucker
pourquoi mais pourquoi il est le boost
pas un peu donc michel a été amical oui
13ème cavale qu'est ce que vous avez
je voulais montrer grille allemand dans
le show business ils sont pas tous comme
ça on pourrait penser cette mais michel
je les ai pas vus depuis au moins dix
ans mais après il fait complètement
laissé tomber
mais toi je n'avais pas vu depuis des
gens seront présents mais moi je t'ai
jamais appelée le 23 décembre aux heures
de concert et tablent d'ailleurs c'est
que ces fabriques horn
ouais comme dirt et capricorne ce sera
beaucoup pardonné bien à ce moment alors
j'aurais dû commencer par là encore il
continue la légende de jean luc lahaye
donc voilà à ce moment là ses disques ne
marche plus et là vous avez aimé ce que
je dirais pas que c'est dire son revers
et push vers lyon la ligne qu'il voit
venir tâche mais quand est ce que tu as
joué contre moi tout le temps
vous avez une prise de conscience jean
luc lahaye vous dites je suis tombé
amoureux de la gloire qui n'est qu'une
prostituée
je m'étais pris à tort pour un homme
heureux
d'un seul coup vous et vos yeux se
disent ils et vous vous découvrez
l'inanité de votre position si ça c'est
un métier on doit assumer absolument
l'enfer et le paradis je pense que c'est
un métier extraordinaire qui m'a apporté
des joies fabuleuse et puis mon des
moments de solitude et de détresse et là
on mange son pain noir et on se plaint
pas mais je me plains pas oui mais c'est
vrai qu'à ce moment là gérard pedro
décèdé et puis voilà quoi et puis vous
là où vivait l'enfer parce que les gens
ce qui est terrible quand on est connu
c'est que les gens dans la journée vide
alors on vous voit plus rien mais non
mais moi je sois se faire refaire le
visage soit changé c'est vrai que les
gens les gens disent on vous voit plus
souvent moi je dis bah vous voyez là
mais ou alors bon ou alors il ya des
gens qui me demandait aussi un moment
qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est-ce que vous devenez là j'ai pas
envie d'engager le combat sans je suis
chauffeur chez ka bersone et même qu'un
jour on m'a cru ouais on a deux jeux la
note pas qu syrie mais pas christine
quand les gens vous voyez vous pose des
questions quand il paraît bonne
est-ce que les gens vous demande ce que
vous devenez oui beaucoup
oui et on leur dit quoi je survis 1 et
la bonne santé je ne suis pas morte et
qu'il faut remercier
qui tutoie les gens quand ils te vois et
et d'espoir maintenant ça va mais quand
j'étais dans la traversée du désert
c'était insupportable j'ai connu ça tu
vas les gros culs très mystique y voir
ta carte
quoique c'est un quart des découpes elle
aussi c'est le jeu d'acteur tab est
coupée sur une mauvaise voie
c'est vrai couple etienne d'abord
sécurité après t'être fait adouber mais
bannis bien non et tu es gentil tu
quittes le plateau bien
donc voilà donc effectivement c'est la
galère vous vivez l'enfer dispute avec
aurélie on va pas insister parce que
vous connaissez cette émission c'est pas
le genre non ça c'est pas du genre non
mais vous faites un morceau qui
s'appelle tu es parti sans laisser de
tendresse qu'ils aillent qui est assez
beau jean luc lahaye voilà pour koné
majax ouais t'as vu ma mère galanter et
alors bon vous revenez là aujourd'hui
avec une compil ou plutôt je dirais la
compil des compiles parce que c'est il
ya tout là dessus en vérité c'est un cd
story sorti avec des titres inédits
première chanson produite par pascal
auriat d'ailleurs à l'époque qui n'ont
pas marché bien avant le succès c'est un
cd story mais sur mon album le 15
janvier un nouvel album the recent
inédite chercheurs pensent nous venions
les moyens d'en acheter qu'un seul il
vaut mieux acheter lequel j'avais qui va
sortir le 15 ou la compil de maintenant
n'était pas obligé d'acheter tout en
même temps tu fais des premiers pour
acheter lequel celui qui se fait plaisir
il y en a neuf n'enlèvera rien alors est
ce que je peux te laisse que peu de
place et la lloyd un bel objet c'est un
objet relier un petit peu quand même
comme un petit livre comme ça avec un
texte au début après il ya le cd tout ça
et le tu veux regarder le texte anti
petit venu lire un extrait du texte
revient c'est très très beau franchement
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas qui a
écrit ce texte mais c'est c'est
quelqu'un qui m'aime bien abba qui vous
aime beaucoup
c'est madame girard retourna sur le sofa
je sentis sont sexy temps je sens et
violations
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
jean lui
avec ses potes
succès
[Musique]
en attendant
dites merci d'avoir utiliser votre carte
de bons clients et d'être revenu alors
la semaine dernière quand vous êtes venu
vendre votre livre pour la première fois
vous allez très très mal vendu
oui très mal mais ça arrive à bercy
n'avait pas expliqué qu'en fait c'est
une parodie de ses livres que font les
intellectuels de la rive gauche
chaque année ils font leur journal alors
il ya jacques julliard ya françois
giroux il ya jean daniel il va là et
vous en fait c'est ça oui mais c'est non
mais c'est difficile de
de vendre quelque chose qu'on a fait
tout seul avec ses petits doigts longs
au fond d'une cave ray donc il n'y a pas
que effectivement les extraits qu'on a
vu la dernière fois il ya des dd des
choses plus longue et plus
pour plus tard et plongeant au coeur
mais c'est difficile juin de l'année
dernière c'est pas moi c'est très très
dur toi car pour moi c'est pas lui oui
je sais bien mais en face à l es tu vas
qu'est ce que je pourrais dire pour
vendre ce livre dans la cave à digérer
[Rires]
non je sais pas je veux dire la
quatrième de couverture on sait bien lui
voilà si tu veux jules edouard moustic
gens mal de moi tom 2003 moustiques
commenta qualité de 2003 comme si son
avis nous intéresser voilà ils essaient
de nous faire croire qu'ils fréquentent
tous les grands de ce monde ce qui n'est
même pas vrai puisqu'il est petit
considérations géopolitiques sur
réaliste des jeunes est un problème avec
george bush ou jacques chirac
voilà c'est votre journal de l'année
jean-marie le pen accélération sur la
vie quotidienne critique gastronomique
et céret comme dirait david lynch bas
[__] wa de bouc
yes vous avez quoi d'autre à ajouter sur
votre livre qui s'appelle donc journal
de moi qui sors 2003 chez flammarion
lundi qui sort lundi sans lundi sera il
sera pas seulement voilà c'est ça que je
vais dire mais oui non alors moustiques
je pouvais gagner
au revoir comme ça
[Musique]
et maintenant à cayenne grimaud
ouais alors là ils sont un petit peu
tous un con quand ils voient hélène
grimaud là c'est une autre chanson
elle a des yeux de louvres il faut pas
la regarder enfin ça c'est ça je vais
regarder mes amis téléspectateurs qui
n'a aucun ami téléspectateurs
chers jeunes une soirée met donc 33 ans
belle comme le jour star du piano reine
des loups c'est à dire musicienne de
renommée mondiale laine gris mort est
compensée par les prix les plus
prestigieux est aussi fondatrice du
centre de conservation des loups dans
l'état de new york
vous sortez un nouveau cd vous publier
un nouveau livre
enfin voilà donc vous êtes toutes les
raisons d'être là ce soir
alors le cd s'appelle credo alors il ya
du beethoven bien sûr mais aussi du john
corigliano ou du arvo part dans ces kiss
et compositeur john crowley note aux
compositeurs américains que j'ai connu à
l écoute d'une symphonie qui la
composent et après la après la mort d'un
de ses amis
ouais et donc j'avais envie de le
connaître mieux et il m'a ensuite fait
passer des partitions des disques des
enregistrements de ses oeuvres c'est
comme ça que j'ai j'ai connu la
fantaisie sur un ostinato way et à vos
pertes c'est un compositeur estonien
c'est un être très un très étrange très
spirituel mais en même temps avec une
très jolie est un sel dans le regard est
en fait très très hot au second degré
pas ce qui m'a être le bienvenu
pardon lieberman je sais pas l'autre
c'est quelqu'un qui a été musicien
[Musique]
on
thierry rolando exige de qui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
oh
et mme guy môquet de chez deutsche
grammophon
[Applaudissements]
quant à lui bien qu'il n'aime pas et là
ça rigolo
vous avez tous que le mur là bravo c'est
trop technique je pourrais dire que vous
préférez plutôt les les notes à droite à
la main droite à droite du clavier que
les notes graves à la gauche j'ai dû
aller en fait j'ai toujours préféré le
registre un grave c'est plus sensuelle
et c'est tout là alors on doit garder
dans le clip parce que là on avait
beaucoup de notes aiguës ce qui s'est
passé ça c'était dans ce passage de
beethoven c'est là que ça se trouve mais
en fait c'est comme ça le détail c'est
toujours dangereux n'a pas été
verrouillée par orlando en vous écoutant
là je réalise que vous avez pris un
accent terrible ans vivant aux
etats-unis non non non ça dépend ce que
je dis est possible si vous me laissez
parler plus longtemps alors l'accent
disparaît oui combien de temps parce que
vous êtes en direct non il faut il faut
pouvoir s'élancer dans les explications
de se succéder
donc c'est hélène grimaud feydeau et
puis encore plus forte encore plus fort
il ya le vivre et l'idc je voudrais que
les gens n'oublient pas qu'ils ont tous
à la capacité de changer le cours des
choses et qu'en fait la tâche la tâche
de changer le monde
incombe à chacun d'entre nous et ça se
fait avec des petites choses ça se fait
avec avec le refus des compromis avec un
avec un sourire avec un regard un acte
de gentillesse et est en fait il ne faut
jamais se résigner
donc c'est pour ça c'est pour ça
si tu parles de ton les parlements de
ces suppliques soit dire quelque chose
sur son livre ça peut l'aider à quel est
le sujet que je le lise avons pensé
qu'il faut le lire d'abord alors c'est
un peu comme dans moby dick y ait une
alternance entre des chapitres sur votre
vie des chapitres sur les loups mais ça
c'est aussi l'idée du disque pour moi
j'ai voulu
j'ai longtemps voulu illustrer
musicalement finalement le comment dire
l'art le concept de l'universalisme tel
que l'a exprimé le poète allemand
novalis qui était à l'origine du
mouvement les romantisme allemand qui
pour moi est la quintessence du
romantisme allemand
et c'est l'idée que finalement tout les
toutes les disciplines que ce soit le
science la religion les humanités le
droit à l'are qu'en fait tout tout c'est
toutes ces choses de la vie sont cons
ils prennent racine dans une dans une
intuition global enfants mais le
romantisme allemand il a ses limites
quand même non non tu vas voir on la
truite
tu veux que je fasse la truite pour
qu'elle voit les limites je suis désolé
jennifer la truite vous allez être
extrêmement déçu par mois mais bon on
est désolé on s'excuse in einem bericht
à eyl dash clos sinfra elle dit là où
nichent forêt le feu rue verdi en paille
et jetant dans des gaines stand hunza in
this all i want is you
[Applaudissements]
chez lui jeudi
hélène grimaud que votre livre parler de
la vie et des loups on va commencer par
la vie dans glee je n'ai aucune
nostalgie de l'enfance pour moi l'enfant
c'est pas un paradis perdu se faisait
une enfance assez solitaire à s'étouffer
par les autres non mais c'est pas comme
ça que j'ai ressenti en fait j'étais
j'étais plus étouffée par moi même
ouais hein parce que finalement j'ai
tout reçu j'ai été privilégié j'ai
toujours reçu de mes parents il m'a
donné l'amour la confiance en moi pour
que je puisse prendre mon envol en fait
qu'elle est là je vous laisse un petit
peu parlé mais vous avez toujours
l'accent il faudrait beaucoup plus c'est
un jeu peut tous nous deux toutes les
nations il fait un froid bipolaire et
fouillées dit rien bisel à pied est-ce
qu'on peut si on veut baisser un petit
peu la cub parce qu'ils vont s'enrhumer
nos deux amis voilà vous êtes bien tous
les deux voilà bien on continue avec la
vie donc rebelles en classe extrêmement
turbulente vous détestez les les enfants
de votre âge passé à social finalement
et heureusement la musique devient un
pont entre le réel et ce que vous avez
dans la tête
cc c'est votre père d'ailleurs qui vous
inscrire un cours de musique par ce qui
se dit il ya qui a que ça pour la pour
la sauver non c'est la musique qui
finalement qui qui m'a captivé c'était
quelque chose qui ce qui était placée
dans l'imaginaire ouais et c'est ce
qu'il me fallait
je vous adore va vraiment arrêter de me
regarder ces visuels ou tirer ses yeux
sont appelés jaloux regarde moi je n'ai
pas compris qu à part ça vous êtes
génial j'ai été reçu premier à
l'unanimité à l'âge de 13 ans au
conservatoire de paris
c'est vrai ça oui c'est vrai mais ça il
y en a tous les ans mais voit aussi le
connaissait madame chirac
non c'est david à 15 ans vous avez le
grand prix de l'académie du disque avec
votre premier enregistrement 16 ans vous
apprenez le piano non ce qu'elle raconte
aussi dans le bouquin c'est comment à 13
ans vous tombée amoureuse du prof c'est
pas mal ça mais ça c'est une belle
histoire parce qu'un premier amour c'est
sacré sacré il avait un certain âge
effectivement amoureuse du profs du
conservatoire à l'âge de 13 ans et
comment vous passez deux ans pour
arriver à vos fins ça faisait partie de
comment dire d'une certaine aussi
impulsivité battu vouloir aller plus
vite être toujours en contact avec des
gens qui a des gens qui avaient une plus
large histoire
donc ça s'inscrit dans ce tracé voilà
bien je vous avais raconté ça à votre
mère évidemment par rapport à certaines
choses j'étais c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
être précoce pour le grand prix du piano
et tous appuyé en même temps voilà
bientôt qui suit si l'on s'immerge on
aimerait que récession il l'a donc après
ses premiers succès vous devenez une
star star petite star mais assez
médiatisé déjà prête des photos dans la
presse et caetera dont elle avec des
froufrous et c est ça vous gave
oui parce que finalement ça qu'on
milliards ça c'est un kart de de la
substance
voilà weimar d'être un chien savant et
vous partez ça se passe un jour à au
festival de la roque d'anthéron 89 vous
avez vraiment envie de disparaître
quoi voilà c'est ça mais c'est bien
parce que ça pousse à combien ça pousse
à un renouvellement à se réinventer vous
disparaissez d'ailleurs venez à new york
vous mangez des boîtes de haricots avec
un camp de toile c'est moi et c'est là
qu'un jour en floride vous rencontrez un
vétéran du vietnam un type assez asocial
qui vous confie sa salle où va la wka il
avoue passer des leçons de piano à danse
avec les loups assez assez rapidement on
est obligé d'abord d'apprendre
effectivement comment ça se gère un loup
parce que c'est pas c'est pas évident tu
vas d'avoir un loup à la maison est ce
qu'à ce moment là on peut dire hélène
que vous vous en sauvage et pour vous
éloigner du piano avec seul ou non je
crois ça va je lui ai toujours été j'ai
toujours été
farouche puis les rêves paradoxalement
c'est grâce aux loups que je me suis
socialiser c'est là d'accord mais
l'année les garçons d'un cahier des
charges lycéens 45 un bon casque jabra
vous finissez par créer dans votre
conservatoire des des loups dans l'état
de new york
alors c'est très marrant c'est nous kate
moss n'est plus oui parce que finalement
quand vous étiez petit vous aviez peur
des loups n'ont pas du tout pas du tout
absolument placer ses services ont
prescrit aucun c'est vraiment celle où
parce que par exemple il faut pas et
nourrira fixe sinon ils ont l'impression
d'être des chiens j'ai du mal à la
nourriture ils ont l'impression d'être
des chiens le grand problème avec le
loup ça je vous le dis ces deux c'est de
faire en sorte qu'ils n'aient pas
l'impression d'être un chien
je veux dire par là un loup ce n'est pas
du tout dangereux pour l'homme ça ne
reconnaît pas l'homme comme 3 l'homme
est un loup pour l'homme et en lamelles
ou non dangereux l'homme est un loup
pour l'homme c'est ça le problème
est ce que le loup peut mordre la main
qui le nourrit n'ont pas pas dans le
sens de dire de d'ingratitude parce
qu'en fait il n'ya on n'est pas dans ce
rapport avec le loup est un animal n'est
pas dans un dans un rapport servile du
tout donc c'est une créature qui garde
son libre arbitre
mais il ya des règles à respecter de
hiérarchie sociale ça n'est marqué très
complexe le problème du loup c'est
qu'ils renvoient pas l'amour qu'on lui
donne un assistant cet animal qui est
sale et mal social par excellence donc
ils achètent les grands-mères ou là il
ya un petit problème relationnel
mais non et les bourses
il ya eu ça prouve bien musclé grands
petits cochons tu es loin d'être réglé
et la bouffe
je suis désolé un jeu tu connais la mort
du loup de l fred et vidal phrase
devenue comme ça je courais sur la lune
enflammé comme sur l' incendie on va
fuir la fumée et les bois étaient noirs
jusqu'à l'horizon nous marchions sans
parler dans l'humide de gazon je connais
par coeur c'est extraordinaire
j'ai une passion pour les lui aussi une
véritable passion pour nous un voisin
auront dès qu'ils élèvent des loups de
manière illicite
il va avoir une fermeture administrative
entre ce jour monsieur il doit voir
cécile nowak
comment ça se passe alors que les loups
sont entrés dans les loups sont entrés
dans paris par ici se fait par ivry les
loups sont entrés dans paris avec la
lyre charmante elvire et loups sont
entrés dans paris saint-denis version
sourds et malentendants il applique toi
de la vie en observant les loups j'ai
appris à vivre vivre dans le moment en
fait ouais parce que c'est vrai que nous
devons souvent tendance à nouveau enfin
je dis ça en tout cas c'est moi c'est
facile de te souvent de ruminer sur le
passé de de penser à ce qui aurait pu
être fait autrement et ou alors par
contre se projeter dans l'avenir et de
passer à côté de de l'instant ouais
c'est c'est dans l'instant c'est
l'intensité des moments qui a qui vaut
la peine qui fait qu'en ce qu'on célèbre
le matin vous et vous savez parler le
loup où ça fait sérieux
je vous avais parlé le loup non non non
ce serait présomptueux de dire çà vous
savez faire des bruits de loups qui a vu
le monsieur fait différents bruits ça ça
hurle pour différentes raisons
moi ça grogne non il ya un abonnement
qui s'appelle à aubrac s'éteint en fait
c'est un c'est un insondable armes pour
pour signaler aux pacéens l'eau tout
c'est pour saigner les optiques il faut
un qu'il faut s'abriter en cas de danger
donc c'est un cessez le son le plus
proche de l'aboiement du film en fait
n'a rien de commun parce que c'est
presque comme une toux a oui c'est
impressionnant
c'était très chien la hausse que l
examen
rendez vous en france encore il ya des
loups et des retours par coup des
matches retour la bb1 radio comme
benneteau est ce qu est ce que vous
préférez les gens ou les loups mais je
choisis les deux promesses que tu dors
l'ouvragé attendent alors des notes ça
peut au moins cinq fois qui pourrait me
la rend ajouté que des vannes de merde
de bellevue a pas de faire des cartes à
points alors oui mais vous conviendrez
que vous êtes une fille un petit peu
spécial ah si on va vous faire une
interview psy
est ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes mégalo non plus c'est à dire
il faut il faut quand même confiance en
soi pour faire ça si l'on ne peut pas
monter sur scène et se livraient mettre
100 % de ce qu'on est
si on n'a pas une confiance en ce qu'on
peut donner rapidement te dirai moi j'ai
été primé à 13 ans elle elle l'a été
ouais ouais je connais pas suspecte ah
non moi je suis entre au conservatoire
13 ans je n'ai pas encore pris mais je
vous aide pas à nos à huy assez
facilement là par exemple non vous
pensez pas que la terre entière vous un
non pas par rapport à un complexe qu'un
complexe de persécution par rapport à
une obsession du détail est ce que vous
êtes schizo non pas du tout la hélène
grimaud de la musique la laine grimaud
des loups n'ont absolument pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes un port du mot mais
non ce n'est pas de carton rouge je n'ai
plus rien est ce que vous êtes cateau
non est ce que vous êtes maniaco oui
enfin ça dépend si vous voulez la
maniaco dépressive no way maniaque oui
legault est ce que vous êtes narciso non
plus à mort pour y est pourtant est-ce
que vous êtes fétiche ou non plus puis
vous êtes assez normal mais alors oui on
remet à l'eau moi j'ai toujours essayé
de
comme libre et de l' esclavage par
rapport à certains certains objets
d'être attaché des choses matérielles
donc en fait le fétichisme ce n'est pas
pour moi mais moi j'étais ado non maso
non il ya une certaine jouissance dans
la souffrance
mais c'est une façon de s'élever way we
vais pas sado maso non vous êtes trop co
je suis quoi rococo vous êtes trio nom
d'un petit 4 mains quand même passer
d'un juge et rio dans l'esprit de la
visite
oui j'aime bien n'hésite plus rien
gardons ce test yazid aux fantasmes et
des ministères c'est un rire et ce temps
là est ce que vous êtes zowie ça suffit
aussi j'ai fait plein d'animaux c'est
bon non mise au pas au nom parce que jo
c'est quand même réducteur mais est ce
que vous êtes
adamo
tiscali c'est ce qu'affirme le rappel
dur vous êtes adamo vous êtes exhibo
n'ont pas non plus est ce que vous êtes
magnéto ah oui ah oui j'aime
l'enregistrement way we made you
[Musique]
le jeu
c'est
j'ai grammophon capelle
là
et maintenant
[Musique]
non
ouais c'est peter gabriel
[Musique]
bonsoir peter gabriel
bonsoir bonsoir mais peter gabriel tu
nous gâte
ouais goût ou parler français anglais
je parle un peu mais peut-être que c'est
plus facile peut-être oui est ce qu'il
ya un traducteur
oui oui tu t'appelles comment robert
comme toujours c'est robert il nous
parle sans l'autre tente et je savais le
par robert comme toujours il sait pas
plus
robert quelque chose maintenant parlons
alors peter gabriel était le leader de
genesis pour un plat de la plus créative
du groupe
ensuite vous avez entamé une carrière
solo commercialement réussi mais
toujours à l'avant garde
vous avez été le premier à vous
intéresser aux musiques du monde
le premier à vous intéresser aux grandes
causes humanitaires
bref j'ai toujours été une espèce de
précurseur ouvert sur le monde et on
écoute ce que vous avez fait didier
oh
qu'est ce
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
bah
à
ça
[Musique]
ap
oui
[Musique]
au monde
à
[Musique]
tu nous tiens
ouais
[Musique]
voilà peter gabriel qui sort lé deuxième
destin de sa carrière qui s'appelle pic
voilà et en même temps via un dvd un dvd
de votre tournée qui s'appelle growing
up tour qui sort et s'était tournée à
milan en 2003 à l'occasion de votre
première tournée internationale depuis
dix ans plus tard gabriel jeu parce
qu'il avait foutu pendant dix ans enfin
c'est la première fois que
[Musique]
c'est vous
pas au bout d'un chemin se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
m
[Musique]
peter gabriel grogne ap live extrait
donc de sa dernière tournée le cancer de
milan voilà la classe la classe big boss
alors parlé un petit peu de votre vie
peter gabriel vous êtes né dans le
surrey en 1950
vous avez les parents idéaux pour
devenir peter gabriel parce que votre
père est ingénieur électricien et il
s'appelle gabriel déjà dépouillé du côté
du nom de famille inventeur génial qui
invente la première version de la télé
câblée finalement votre perdant hier
faisait bouillir les faits c'était un
système de télévision câblée qui
s'appelait talla programme
voilà ça vous donne une idée pour vous
donner une idée de ce que c'était il
fallait avoir accès à ces télés par un
système de téléphone de 40 téléphonique
c'est compliqué voilà en tous les cas
voilà donc votre père était un
électronicien on voit bien pourquoi
après vous êtes branché d'ananguié du
yoga en plus s'explique aussi beaucoup
de choses et votre mère était pianiste
vous a donné des leçons de piano mais
vous a aussi fait donner des leçons de
danse d'équitation pas vraiment une
enfance parfaite petite révolution 9 ans
je l'avais un peu demain avant de
recevoir des leçons tout le temps un peu
un petit peu comme vous un moment mais
lui c'est à 9 ans et s'est révolté
contre tout ça il a dit j'en ai marre
des leçons de piano des leçons dans des
leçons d'équitation et tout ça mais ses
parents lui ont dit fais gaffe tu vas le
regretter et en fait c'est vrai vous
l'avais regretté après en effet quelques
fois parce que justement j'ai pas pu
toujours exprimé ce que je voulais à
travers mais mes doigts ma main mais
quand même j'aurais préféré gagner un
peu plus apte et les nerfs voilà et
ensuite le collège et c'est au collège
que vous avez rencontré ceux avec qui
vous formerez le fameux groupe genesis
alors ce qu'on peut dire pour les plus
jeunes parce que tu es n'existerait que
se dote pas quand même dire c'est que
genesis a toujours eu une vision assez
conceptuel
et progressiste du rock and roll c'est
ce qu'on peut dire c'est à dire qu'à
l'époque on essaie de mélanger
différentes influences différents styles
musicaux
voilà en 1971 la formation définitive
est en place avec phil collins
vous avez toujours rêvé d'être un grand
batteur non c'est pas un grand regret
pour vous deux oui en tout cas j'étais
très enthousiaste j'avais pas le même
talent que phil collins
donc pour moi l'envié des boîtes à
rythme ce qui nous a permis de
d'exprimer un peu tout ça de manière
artificielle qui m'a bien plu lequel des
deux est le plus riche aujourd'hui
or monsieur fait certainement bien plus
riche que moi sans aucun doute alors ce
qui nous a beaucoup surpris à l'époque
quand on a vu arriver
genesys c'est votre idée d'utiliser les
maquillages les masques les costumes
vous par exemple vous faisiez des
concerts où vous aviez une tête de
renard ou alors vous arriviez avec des
ailes de chauve souris en maintenant ça
a l'air de rien mais c'est vrai qu'au
début des années 70 c'était très très
surprenant il est vrai sans choquer un
peu d'ailleurs c'était amusant de jouer
avec cette façon de choquer le public de
seconde en tout cas et puis en même
temps il y avait beaucoup de guitare
acoustique qui était tout le temps
déréglé kiné désaccordé plus tôt et
c'était la responsabilité du chanteur de
distraire le public en quelque sorte le
divertissement
donc j'ai commencé à raconter des
histoires illustrées ces histoires et
puis ensuite les jouets sur scène soit
qu'on peut dire que genesis a introduit
la théâtralité dans l'europe quelque
chose qui n'existait pas avant
alors évidemment il ya eu un énorme
succès avec ses vignes england by the
pound est l'apogée est atteinte pour
genesys avec des lames leisen broadway
et la corsa c'est incroyablement le
groupe est à son apogée
vous quittez le groupe disons que
je n'avais un petit peu assez d'aller
dans le sens du groupe c'est à dire que
tout avait été prêt à organiser en
quelque sorte un des années avant je
savais très bien où j'allais être
vannetais l'endroit t le moment souhaité
préprogrammés puis ensuite avec la
naissance de mon premier enfant il ya eu
un problème en soi mais un problème à
l'accouchement et là d'un seul coup vous
avez pris conscience vous vous êtes dit
finalement il y avait de ça il y avait
d'autres priorités ça c'est certain
et puis parce que j'étais parents
j'étais papa je vienne avant les autres
membres du groupe
les autres n'avaient pas beaucoup de
sympathie pour bon après ça votre époque
solo commence
vous commencez par par découvrir on peut
dire la world music
un soir en zappant sur un un poste de
radio en ondes moyennes
oui c'est effectivement la première fois
que je me dis voilà quelque chose que je
pourrais utiliser moi même dans ma
propre dans ma propre musique
mais j'aimais beaucoup les les radios à
ondes courtes surtout j'écoutais de la
musique africaine sur une petite un
cessionnaire landaise me rappelle des
rythmes africains les voit tout cela
semblait présenter notre image la
musique quelque chose de tout à fait
passionnant alors peter gabriel vous
défendez vraiment depuis des années
toutes les musiques du monde
est ce que vous vous défendriez ça
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour pas bien sûr et bien
c'est tout est musique moderne mondiale
n'importe quelle musique
il ya même ceux là voilà je fais péter
pressing pour voir filer blindés
[Musique]
avenue
ma
de good speedboat anyway ensuite vous
lancer dans les actions humanitaires
amnistie witness vous êtes une espèce de
citoyens du monde
d'ailleurs vous avez une idée de l'unité
pour diriger le monde ce serait un
comité des sages avoue penser que en
fait il faudrait renforcer l'onu et qui
a un comité des sages et lui qui dirige
le monde
oui ça ce serait une façon ils ont
utilisé des personnes qui ont une
certaine expérience du monde de la vie
mais alors le problème souvent dans la
classe politique c'est que les hommes
politiques ne pensent qu'à la prochaine
échéance électorale donc l'état c'est
difficile de faire intervenir des
politiques qui aura une incidence sur le
long terme
alors si par exemple on pense la culture
des indiens d'amérique examiner leurs
politiques sur des périodes de sept
plusieurs générations c'était les tribus
des anciens qui prévoyait les politiques
des générations à venir et seulement
alors il y a encore sûr s'il ya des
personnes qui ont autorité morale mais
qui n'ont pas de poids symbolique et il
semble dommage de ne pas se servir de ce
talent de manière plus constructive
surtout maintenant qu'il a technology là
pour le faire bien alors vous intéresser
à peu près à tout multimédia et au
bonobo blanc au bonobo
tu sais que les bonobos sont notre plus
proche cousin robin 19 % de nos mamans
avec l'homme contrairement à patrick il
en a que 2 90%
voilà il ne pense qu'à baiser et gabriel
dit que finalement on a beaucoup
d'arrogance parce que si on arrivait sur
une planète et qu'on trouve des êtres
avec 99% de gênes identique au nôtre en
longs les respecterai alors que là nous
on se prend pour des génies les bonobos
on les prend pour des primates ignan
c'est vrai c'est l'intérêt pour la
musique qui m'a amené vers les bonobos
on a commencé à jouer au piano ensemble
et puis il y avait effectivement une
intelligence musicale en présence là
c'était quelque chose de vraiment
passionnant maintenant ce que nous
essayons de faire
je crois qu'il ya une douzaine de ce
crime at qui comprennent notre de notre
langue
on essaie de les connecter par internet
et leur donner les moyens de communiquer
entre eux d'abord et il ya également un
perroquet africain qui a beaucoup de
talent qui vous intéressait vraiment à
tous vous êtes intéressé à un moment à
rosanna arquette aussi un bon c'est vrai
rien de très intéressant une fois je
l'interviewais rosanna arquette et julie
c'est marrant quand même rosanna vous
êtes toujours avec des musiciens et
comment ça se fait et il m'a répondu
c'est sans doute parce que j'aime leur
instrument
j'imagine que vous avez un instrument de
qualité
vous êtes aussi intéressé à chênée
d'o'connor 1 l'intéressé vraiment à tous
chenet d'o'connor vous avez déclaré en
parlant d'elle c'est une montagnes
russes émotionnelles ça veut dire quoi
ça il y avait des hauts des bas des
soubresauts des rebondissements très
rapide à des rebondissements très rapide
bien peter vous êtes une vraie rockstar
alors on va voir peter gabriel 6 30 ans
après genesis vous êtes encore une vraie
rockstar et on va faire une interview
rockstar
[Musique]
pic à cabriès que vous avez saccagé la
chambre du palace dans lequel vous êtes
descendus à paris non non non face se
mouiller pour nous il fallait il fallait
laisse ne pas toucher aux abonnés
c'était peut-être la chose la plus
dangereuse qu'on ait jamais faite
est-ce que vous boxez régulièrement des
paparazzis pas souvent pas régulièrement
est-ce que défi affirme régulièrement
que les enfants qu'elles ont de vous oh
oui toujours
c'est très rock star des femelles il
faut faire attention avec l'allégorie
qui sont peut-être un peu jaloux
est-ce que vous avez des ennuis
judiciaires à cause de la drogue font
pas souvent non
c'est d'ailleurs une histoire bien
tragique
est ce que vous avez acheté un
restaurant une boîte de nuit qui vous a
ruiné tout à fait non je plaisante m
peut-être un petit hôtel par contrat et
ça vous a coûté dublet hénaff ne font
pas mal oui est ce que vous êtes
tellement rockstar que plus personne
n'ose vous contredire quand vous dit une
connerie
non non les gens me contredise tout le
temps 1 est ce que vous choisissez dans
le public tous les soirs une fille qu on
vous ramène après dans votre chambre
pour pas une seule
peter gabriel merci d'avoir été avec
nous je sais que votre avion vous attend
sur le tarmac et que vous décollez pour
l'angleterre
mon vélo aussi votre vélo aussi merci
piqueur
[Musique]
dambach
et maintenant
[Musique]
m
à cibler l'ict martin
[Musique]
et veut pas dire mais franchement il ya
des gonzesses dans cette émission non
y'a de la mort bénédicte martin mesdames
messieurs danse et en lisant une
chronique de patrick besson dans
marianne que j'ai découvert votre livre
qui s'appelle warm up
c'est à dire tour de chauffe on peut
dire là qui est publié chez flammarion
et on vous voyant sur la couverture on
pourrait penser que c'est un livre
érotique et patrick
c'est érotique mais ça n'est pas que ça
bénédicte martin beaucoup de cul c'est
plein de jolies phrases à vous gardez
votre sac à main sur les genoux
ah j'aime bien ça fait province j'adore
voilà non c'était aux tic votre bouquin
c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas que ça
c'est plein de jolies phrases et et paul
morand aurait adoré a dit patrick besson
ce qui est quand même un grand
compliment 1
alors nicolas rey lui vous compare à
ennery miller eric dahan vous adore vous
êtes la hype littéraires de l'automne bx
martin est très heureux de vous avoir
sur ce plateau
et puis c'est vrai que tout ça s'inscrit
dans le boom actuel des livres érotiques
voire pornographiques écrits par des
femmes
il ya un boom là dessus en ce moment il
ya alors warm up c'est un recueil de
textes courts souvent à caractère sexuel
une espèce de catalogue des pratiques on
peut lire mans oui mais c'est enfin il
s'est fait dans ce but la whey la
plupart sont autobiographiques photo
c'est dommage même si parfois vous vous
mettez dans la dans la peau d'un mec
la première nouvelle ces petits textes
courts comme sa petite nouvelle est
c'est un mec qui est excité quand c'est
un havre ac ses copains laquelle on lit
mais la première si vous voulez réaliser
la robe que tu portes est aussi folle
que ton esprit je lui déchirer ce soir
en rentrant de cette fête tout le monde
te regarder ton cul ça chiffre
s'affichait aux yeux de tous dont saint
est sorti de ton corsage et un orgue et
la soirée je t'ai vu embrasser deux
autres garçons vous et allez vous cacher
loin de moi
ce petit jeu semblait beaucoup amusé ton
regard ce soir et si peu celui d'une
amoureuse les mêmes d'une femme c'est
celui d'une idiote arrivée dans
l'appartement je bouillonnais tu t'es
pencher pour poser ton sac à terre et la
soul et offre monte face sont apparus ce
soir je ne sais pas si ton corps me
répugne ou m'enchante tête elle en
aiguille te donner l'air d'une fille à
plaisir sans aucune profondeur excepté
celle de ton sexe à ce moment là j'ai
arraché sa robe
tu as été emportés avec le tissu que je
maintenais fermement et que je secret
les coutures craquer la fibre cdg été
traîné jusqu'au lit était baiser sans
égards tout sèche et tes yeux
s'écarquillent est plein de larmes
tu gesticulait de crise fait arrêter de
me regarder vous parce que là on ne peut
pas à la fois écouter ça et vous avez vu
que vous regardez je suis un être humain
je suis pas en bois hélène je suis
désolé à un moment pareil
les animateurs de télé multi harris
continuer continuer mais carey se sont
fait alors plus douce tu me lécher les
doigts ainsi s'épanouissent et la fille
ingrate entendre amante ma jalousie
calme et je me suis assoupi les yeux
ouverts fixant un plafond
tu t'es endormi avec le corps rougi
méthode bigarrée gisait au sol
pourquoi ça m'excite autant que tu
dragues les copains alors on va faire un
truc spécial ce soir on va faire l'anti
portrait chinois chaud
[Musique]
alors belgique si vous étiez un pays
chaud je serai la guadeloupe
ouais mais la thaïlande dossier vous
êtes originaire de là-bas ouais ouais
si vous étiez un film chaud emmanuel
c'est bien emmanuel moi ça va beaucoup
marc emmanuel quand j'ai vu manuel ma
sexualité a changé grossemy si vous
étiez une boisson chaude un chocolat
chaud
vous étiez une mer chaude maintiennent
tout cela je retire pour les affaires on
a dit pardon alors la mer de caraïbes
ouais c'est bien pour les caraïbes si
vous étiez une confidence chaude
[Musique]
et
une amie qui me qui me jugent très dans
l'oreille sa première fellation si vous
étiez un vent chaud le sirocco vous
étiez une époque chaude 69
si vous étiez un plat chaud brandade de
morue aux ottaviens vérifier si vous
étiez un mec chaud les miens comment il
est alors très beau très beau
il a un métier tout ça va il a mis les
lâchers seront ils avaient dîné et la
peau qu'est ce que vous voyez bien pas
parce que d'un métier comment il
s'appelle benjamin benjamin flament
didon si vous étiez un souvenir chaude
parce que dans mon bouquin si vous étiez
un objet chaud mon scooter
si vous étiez un artichaut hardy chaud
[Musique]
est ce qu'on a mais une amie chrome en
benjamins tenez benjamin attention
abidjan c'est très bien donc benjamin
c'est vous donc l'homme show de notre
ami bénédicte martin ça doit pas être
facile tous les jours une bande s comme
ça à la maison vous faites comment
brasserie un traducteur en région n'ont
jamais un sérieux comment vous faites
c'est un sacré pistolet quand même mais
c'est impossible c'est à dire que je
suis obligé de me battre toutes les 5
secondes avec les gens ouais
heureusement je suis assez musclé donc
je me défends comme je te veux quoi dire
capables bouquin comme ça beaucoup de
mecs vont se jeter sur elle en imaginons
qu'elle est chaude en sachant qu'elle
est chaude au le fou
donc votre fiancée c'était c'était
le matelas
à
[Applaudissements]
warm up
[Musique]
et maintenant j'accueille elvis presley
m
non
[Musique]
quand je pense que certains pensent que
vous êtes mort didier
[Applaudissements]
jean marie
maya
non
on en reparlera les chiens
[Musique]
on essaie
m
je ne vois pas
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
le parking
nous en sommes
auj
tout haut
[Musique]
vous êtes
m
[Musique]
on se tait
la famille
au monde sous cape au vent
[Musique]
non pas que je raconte
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
e
et le monde voilà bravo merci merci
l'ami
musique à toute heure que le mendez
c'est pas le morceau
allo
et maintenant j'accueille quillot
[Musique]
manque un siège pour cela mérite d'être
la porte est à mon avis salut ça va
alors les quais où là je connais vos
tubes parker parce que mes enfants
jouent ça à fond tous les week-ends
alors voilà ce que j'entends le week-end
chez moi même c'est pas mal sinon vous
seriez pas là
j'ai vu
j'ai eu
on n'a pas tout
les schémas
temps
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
juste un peu de place pour ne pas qu'on
m'efface j'peux pas trop d'amis regardez
donc la cipa excellent coup d'espoir je
suis seul eh bien ça
[Musique]
g
run akiyo l'album s'est vendu à 700
milles exemplaires
sept cent mille exemplaires blé ce qui y
est orlando est toujours là qu'est
orlando exigent les pipes
de la tuque
[Musique]
je suis
je cours c'est nouveau single de bio bon
à ce qu'on écoute
voilà ce qu'on écoute chez les arts 10
ans à fond la caisse pendant le week-end
non non franchement c'est pas mal non
non c'est assez voilà alors mes enfants
l'adoraient être là pour vous poser
eux-mêmes les questions je vais vous
poser mais bon c'est la semaine dernière
ses vacances là c'est plus des vacances
alors ils m'ont préparé des monts
préparé des questions
je leur ai demandé voici l'interview a
redit tout
[Musique]
et ils m'ont dit et il m'a dit papa soit
gentil avec eux en plus allez vous à
devoir de réserve vraiment bon alors je
vais poser c'est les questions de mes
enfants c'est pas mal parce que c'est
des questions qu'on entend la télé est
généralement d'ailleurs il pourrait
faire des animations
alors pourquoi le groupe s'appelle clio
alors qu'ils ont fait c'est parce que
nous on aime beaucoup les jeux vidéo les
mangas et certainement asiatiques
ouais voilà on a pris parce qu'on a mais
la sonorité le fait que ce soit court
alors continue avec les questions des
enfants ardisson est ce que vous
connaissiez avant de former le groupe
ouais bien sûr fait dix ans qu'on se
connaît et qu'on joue ensemble ouais
ouais on est des cons c'est connu au
collège on fait bien
depuis quand kg existe-t-il donc ça fait
dix ans est-ce que vos paroles s'en sont
inspirés de votre vie ouais vous n'êtes
pas aussi malheureux que dans les dix
quand même non non non non maintenant
maintenant tout va mieux en fait ouais
des faits que vous avez du succès vous
êtes malheureux ouest ce qui fait qu'on
a beaucoup plus de mal à écrire en fait
avec les centristes
est ce que quand on s'est fait larguer
c'était plus facile
ouais ouais est ce que vous venez d'une
est ce que vous venez d'une famille de
musiciens
pipo et tout ce genre de trafic
quelles sont nos héros donne pas mal de
des groupes comme radiohead muse c'est
un héros chez naughty dog pearl jam tout
ça absolument c'est votre unir vannes a
aussi bien sûr j'imagine fait quand on
écoute c'est un peu ça oui alors une
question des enfants à part votre cd
qu'est ce que vous écoutez en ce moment
à un coup de plaintes un truc quand
sortira votre prochain cd en septembre
2004 a priori c'est dans longtemps
non c'est pas ça aussi bon bah oui c'est
sûr intéressés ils sont allés vous voir
à paris donc en concert dernièrement
vous allez rencontrer jean maurice
autographes d'ailleurs alors est ce que
vous allez faire d'autres concerts à
l'olympia le 15 novembre
le caravage voilà c'est pas seulement
voir venir avec un piia est ce que ça
vous embête de faire de la promo télé
avec papa
non mais dit s'être écoulé en plein et
c'est pas pour cirer les pompes pour
quoi que ce soit mais ça fait vachement
en tant qu on a envie de passer ici avec
nous on est ravi d'avoir toute façon
[Applaudissements]
donné mes enfants vous déteste la raison
pour laquelle je ne posera aucune
question soit préparé mon papa qui danse
avec les loups et soit partie et les
massicois aleba la voilà la grille sur
le coup charest et d'hélène grimaud est
magnifique
alors est ce que vous feriez la star ac
je sais pas trop c'est en fait on est en
tournée en ce moment n'a vraiment pas le
temps elle est pourrie cette réponse
était un truc un peu plus méritants si
on avait le temps je sais pas en fait il
se trouve que c'est un petit peu
compliqué nous on a des fans qui nous
considère un peu comme l'alternative
devrait en revanche nous nous a toujours
dit je pense que c'est vrai que quel que
soit l'environnement dans lequel on est
si on reste le même on fait notre truc
et voilà nous personnellement la star ac
ça ne me dérange pas comment comme on
dit toujours il ya des artistes qui
sortent de là il y en a qui sont
talentueux à qui le sont pas du tout
faut bien le reconnaître
est-ce que vous avez des petites amies
c'est mes filles qui demande sa taille
normale mais à un affaire bien levé xi
et des dix amis ça beaucoup les décevoir
elle s'appelle comment nos petites amies
ouais en fait moi je suis un peu à part
j'en est de temps en temps avant même sa
création d'un seul coup là non mais
c'est à dire que il ya une fille que
j'aime vraiment qui je suis à sept
pendant très longtemps mais il se trouve
que si je restais lesquels je vais me
marier je pense que je suis trop jeune
pour ça c'est parce que c'est beau titia
s'est dit fier elle a quel âge
mais qu elle est trop bien pour toi non
mais moi mais je ne regarde il regarde
là probablement basique 8 rebonds abat
je crois que c'était pas mal non non
mais dis lui qui a fait j'ai déposé quad
et lui je le ferai plus tard dans cinq
ans c'est à titien reconnais nous non
elle un peu plus [__] la vôtre mais
oui donc la vienne et koch naturellement
mais c'est important
[Musique]
j'ai pas le choix
oh
j'accueille maintenant martin fontaine
[Musique]
bonsoir c'est dingue martin fontaine qui
était la soirée à mogador donc un
spectacle que vous avez déjà interprété
1500 fois devant un million de
spectateurs car elle vit story a été
créée il ya neuf ans au capitole de
québec
voilà vous été choisi pourquoi parce que
franchement moi je vais vous dire un
truc je vous vois arriver dans un
casting pour faire un avis prestige vous
prend pas je sais on chercher l'âme
d'elvis 1 que pas nécessairement l'image
vont chercher un artiste qui pouvait à
la fois
jouer musiciens chanteurs excusez moi
allez vous êtes très bon en elvis mais
vous avez un accent de merde
ouais je sais mais c'est pas mal mais il
faut vous entendre parler anglais
elle est vraiment très bon non voilà
donc en beaux-arts on vous a choisi
parce que vous aviez l'âme plutôt que le
nook web 1
c'est ça ouais ouais ouais c'est vrai
nom vous avez un truc quand vous faites
elvis moi je les regardais tout à
l'heure vous avez ce truc c'est qu'ils
relevé la moitié de ça ouais il relevé
un petit peu ça lève comme alain moatti
tout à fait ces exactions styrie
d'amendé jusqu'à demain pour retrouver
ses vrais fait le coup de la nef pour
voir hp pas l'egypte lui haïti est
retourné dans sa tombe
alors le lancement en france est assez
important parce que vous dites que
effectivement si ce spectacle a du
succès en france ça peut lui donner une
envergure internationale
le texte a été revu et corrigé par
christian blachas c'est humain est un
elvis magnifique je trouve que ça a
amené le show un autre niveau au plus
étant donné que christian et
journalistes et tout est un amoureux
d'elvis 1 et je pense que ça amène le
show vraiment un autre niveau est un
spécialiste quand même d'aider des
réinterprétations parce que vous aviez
un groupe qui s'appelait de wils way
legear enseigner aux toujours et qui
faisait des reprises des beatles et des
stones
ouais moi je
je pense que les beatles m'ont vraiment
tout appris au niveau musical
ils m'ont appris l'anglais ils m'ont
appris comment écrire des chansons faire
les arrangements musicaux vocaux et tous
et elvis pour moi
signifiait plus le showman vrai que que
juste la musique alors tous les soirs
donc il ya deux heures de maquillage
vous transformer en elvis
qu'est-ce qu'on change ont les cheveux
on a compris qu est-ce qu on change on
vous m'aider non il n'y a aucun rajout
on n'utilise que des ombres et lumières
dans la casse et c'est du maquillage de
base fond de teint bien on va regarder
un petit peu on va vous comparez à elvis
presley en regardant un extrait du
spectacle à mogador ça s'appelle elvis
story marié tous
[Musique]
pas
jean
lula et moi
[Musique]
non
voilà
ça
[Musique]
médecin
e
le chef
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
oui
viva
[__]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà le mystérieux à baiona je pensais
honnêtement
honnêtement c'est assez étonnant surtout
quand on sait que c'est là et c'est un
chant t'es vraiment les chansons la
musique et live c'est pas des playback
voilà quatre musiciens six choristes
et moi c'est marrant ça ressemble un peu
alice presse les faux nom c'est
vachement bien vraiment coïncidence non
mais c'est très très bien c'est vrai
c'est un bon spectacle à force d'être
elvis presley il ya sûrement des
similitudes au bout d'un moment entre
vous et votre modèle sur scène donc on
va faire une interview comme elvis
[Musique]
alors martin fontaine est ce que comme
elvis presley vous trouver pathétique
les gens qui s'habillent en elvis
presley oui oui oui absolument
oui est ce que comme elvis vous avez un
goût de chiottes pour choisir vos
costumes
ah non on a des stylistes magnifique
est ce que comme elvis vous pourriez
tomber amoureux d'une fille de 15 ans
oui tout à fait est ce que comme elvis
vous avez des pompes en daim bleu
non malheureusement est ce que comme
elvis tout le monde croit que vous êtes
mort
et n'entend pas ce blind test l'addition
je sois aux platines j'accueille
quotidienne bonsoir leur vous connaissez
le principe je veux l'interprète
évidemment donc au début à moustiques
c'est bien tu va les aider un petit peu
bon bah tu préfère le mot clé gmac a
résonné à la carte
il a réduit la peine bien donc je veux
l'interprète au début on joue par équipe
donc l'équipe d'elvis presley contre
l'équipe de jean-luc l'ice à peu près
comparable et bien ensuite à partir des
banques aux et des super banco c'est
chacun pour sa gueule mais là messieurs
tu es pris à outils ok c'est bien
premier titre à toi interprète
j'avais peur
on a droit tour
je suis
[Musique]
merci seigneur et ça fait 1 0 pour la
bombe vers l'est elvis presley du monde
messieurs attention à outils de web
m
[Musique]
attention
donc c'est des valeurs suez
effectivement bravo le point pour
l'équipe de jean luc lahaye attention
continue naughty numéro 3 damadola
d'ailleurs soufflage ici dans le pos
valant
[Musique]
bon
quand yann jouffre j si le voir à la
hausse et les matelas donc voilà là
lloris
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
weston
[Musique]
haïti
nord avec qui donna summer et
m
c'est vrai
[Musique]
m
hamon
on en est à quatre points pour l'équipe
de jean luc lahaye il faut dire bravo
jean luc annaix tennis c'est un fait le
ménage quand tu le torse wii et qui peut
lui se pressent les 1 point attention
nos outils numéro 6
[Musique]
comment
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai l'impression de martin fontaine le
faire taire henson darby prochain
spectacle à bientôt et on prépare on
prépare un choix aussi très très bien là
bon donc ça fait quand même quatre
points pour les deux points pour elvis
presley
comme quoi attention la outils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
belkacem
m
paquita
de sean paul
[Musique]
si on continue dernier morceau
m
besson
je dois dire que dès que c'est un peu
plus récents les qui aussi qu'au barça
fait qu'on arrive à 4 4 finalement à la
fin à la famille par écrit donc envolée
qui ont remonté les clients les enfants
devraient ce canton glacée à kiyonari
vos matchs nuls et à partir de
maintenant évidemment c'est le chacun
pour sa gueule avec un succès limpide
français du français louis a dû il ya du
français effectivement pas beaucoup il
ya deux n'y a pas de français de penser
il ya juste un bon coup et maintenant
vous entendez à lui maintenant quand
même c'est le dj qui fait sa liste et
donc si nos outils djika café saïss
allons-y le banco ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours pendant six mois
d'octobre
non là laurent était impérial je veux
dire parce que il ya des choses ils
reconnaissent une chanson française et
tous mais la halde jarreau j'ai écouté
ça dans ma chambre de bonne pendant dix
ans après sa retraite avec une vision de
ces gars comme hélène ségara qui vous
fait tant qu elle a vingt quinze mètres
carrés moi j'avais 9 m² et une bouffée
d'eric aubin grande toile fait tout ce
qui concerne la cellule voilà vous à
tous torche et mercy nothing merci
beaucoup bravo pour ta sélection je
crois qu'on peut lire laurent c'était
tout le monde en parle je crois que
maintenant je crois que les gens s'en
sont rendus compte c'est la facture
essentiel je crois que les gens l'ont vu
à moi je pense qu avec christine
deviers-joncour viendrait donc c'était
tu voies parallèles en mairie
[Musique]
chez michel lafon jean cau
legault
une piscine d
mariane pearl un coeur invaincu chez
plon jean luc lahaye réouverture de la
discothèque le studio créé 187 le 19
novembre
[Musique]
l'album s'appelle jean luc lahaye hélène
grimaud l'arrière sont sauvages chez
robert laffont
kl album chez deutsche grammophon
s'appelle credo peter gabriel
l'album s'appelle bits et la vhs et dvd
c'est le penseur waring ap l'aïe
bénédicte le matin web chez flammarion
martin fontaine elvis toyota canada
jusqu'au 2 janvier 2004 et puis l'album
qui s'appelle elvis story qui o
l'album s'appelle le chemin le nouveau
single s'appelle je cours
ils sont en tournée dans toute la france
le 15 novembre à l'olympia paris le 9
février aussi olympiades paille voilà
notre ticket merci le dvd with the boss
bruno solo yvan le bolloc'h la fédé
caméra café chez diane gueule excellent
la viande novembre
you en hommage à marc vivien foé avec
sonny anderson
thierry ans
robert pires les bénéfices du match
seront remercié la famille de faux
reporters sans frontières met en vente
trois calendriers 2004 au prix de 12
euros au profit de tous les journalistes
emprisonnés dans le monde voilà c'est
les tournants talent et maintenant
l'écoutent un outil de génération
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si l'asie
c'est le bio bio s s est dit ou pas
ignorer c'est que l'on se plaît à
l'achat de danse et je te sens l'excité
fait pourtant tu vas le cacher on se
saoule vite refusé
en plus des noms c'est toujours le même
test la phase aller sans cesse quand il
s'agit de sexe tu aimes ça je vais te
donner
[Musique]
tout de suite pourquoi l'ignorer tous ou
de validité souche à terre ou mal guérie
mais reconnaissez
rituel devant au classement derrière on
seul but refusé en prime et lens est
toujours les mêmes chaînes regarde ce
gène prospal en titre est tu aimes ça je
mets tant donné
il
je suis un guide qu'elle a dans le slip
qui arriveront dans le pré puyricard
attribuait plein ça ici
[Musique]
et tu mon amour des deux premiers soirs
déjà dans l'hôtel dans le noir du bois
il faut pas la faire faire faut faire
des affaires faire bio combattants de
l'ennui final chaque partie pas de
charge aujourd'hui c'est jeudi
[Musique]
qui
moi ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
vous êtes un
la technique technique s'est encore fait